[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday yep it's my favorite show of the
week
yep yeah because this is the show where
we drink and interact and we can talk
about anything is basically open lines
Friday yeah it was just really fun yep
we can uh could be anything we could
talk about anything um and um of course
um you can Aspire the direction of the
conversation by your [__] crazy ass
comments in the comment section sure I
mean you know I see motorcycle Zack in
there bule Zach Zack on the bule is in
there and gay Zac is in there gay Zac
and
bu
yeah yeah everybody has to well you know
when when people have the same name you
have to you have to designate yeah B
Zack we were talking today he's uh
getting ready to come down here for bike
week oh that's right coming up soon huh
yeah he's going he's going to meet up up
uh with me at the Oasis I might ride
back with him to [__] to the um to
see what's happening
atona yeah daytonas how far from used
this it's about an hourish oh is that
far hour and maybe hour and 15 I thought
it was about a half hour no cuz I worked
in Daytona remember and it took about an
hour takes about hour to get there yeah
but it's not a boring ride it seems to
go by pretty fast yeah it's not too bad
yeah um you know another thing up there
um bu Zack is um on the way the Cabbage
Patch is there yeah you can stop at the
Cabbage Patch that's the that's the
[__] this the Astro Dome of [__]
biker bars there that place is [__] up
yeah it's been there like forever been
there forever yeah I can I can hear your
thing it's like I can hear our voices
like talking like 5 seconds behind hear
I can hear you got that super Heering I
don't though I'm actually kind of
deaf but I can just
hear coming from over there theable he's
got all weak up there okay yeah that's
cool yeah Chris will probably be around
on his [__] Triumph Rocket 3 [__]
super bike it looks like something out
of damn Aira it's [__] wild he's got
that he's got a big dog got a Big Dog
Chopper I'll have to run up to the Oasis
and hang out with you for yeah I don't
usually go up there much cuz I got to
drive I don't got to I don't got to yeah
J be with me probably she wants to
go yeah he was up there you were up at
Oasis not yesterday but the day before
yesterday yeah what was it Wednesday
yeah yeah you see I don't have really
any two up Riders everything I have is a
solo Rider so she's got to come in a
car yeah so he usually just goes up
there and says he's up there so and then
I just drive up there it's not that far
but you know uh bartender Amy is
wondering where I was yeah so yeah she's
trying to get in the middle of a Tom and
Jenny
sandwich she's not ashamed of it either
she's just like she show pictures and
[__] and it's it's funny because she
actually lives across the street for
month
yeah she's seen some of the stuff that
we make some the video I showed it to
her and she's like damn I'm getting hot
I was like she's going to be crawling in
our window night she knows where we she
said she said she says you tell Jen you
know y'all know that I just live across
the street from you I got nothing to
I ain't got nothing to do I'll show her
I if you come to Oasis [__] if you come
to Oasis she'll be there seems like
she's always working there every time I
go there she's there yeah I'll show her
to
you oh my god so
funny yeah there's some people I that
whose names I haven't seen in a while
Karen's here uh listening from the UK
whilst babysitting my three- week old
grandson holy crap that's a little
little baby hey I feel like I haven't
seen you around in a while I don't maybe
you have been but I you know maybe I
just didn't see the name in the chat uh
Danny says what's the temperature in
Florida right now it's like 70 no not
right now it's not my computer says it's
48 but I don't know if that's
accurate it was actually kind of warm
today cuz Tom went out on a ride and I
think it was like 70 degrees Yeah that's
Amy yeah yeah she lives across theet
Lake on the farm across the street
across the street from our neighborhood
you know what I mean so I kept telling
it's like it said you keep tell you keep
showing her like the the porn and stuff
she's going to like come over here yeah
she loves Jen she she loves J she is so
Freddy I'm gonna get some of
that she try she's the type that you'd
be in [__] bed you hear her knocking
on the window that's what I I'm coming
in there yo move
aside yo move aside cuz she does yeah
yeah she she just lives right there yeah
she Liv right
there I got some other [__] funny
[__] of her it's just like
away I can't see
[Laughter]
it it's all
natural all
natural yeah she's funny as [__]
yeah see there was another one that I
had her where I was [__] sitting
there drinking and she was [__] with
me remember
that I think it's I don't know I don't
know what you're talking about
let if I can find it I might not have it
anymore what was she
doing this might be it right here this
is it right here I can't see it oh okay
I think yeah she's over my [__]
shoulder in there oh yeah yeah yeah
that's right I think [__] trying
trying to strip and [__] I think he
should yeah
yeah sitting there taking a video
drinking and she's over my shoulder her
[__]
stripping yeah that's she's she's
hilarious she's very funny
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I don't think you've never
been to Bike Week have you uhuh well no
I've been to bike week but local bike
week not not Daytona Bike not Daytona
Bike Week I mean I kind of had to go cuz
I lived there so from you know the local
Riders here kind of see bike week as
like tour
time they don't so much go to um Daytona
usually they'll go to their local or
hangouts and you know guys ride through
there too yeah then they might they
might take a ride up there and just show
up pass through you know maybe they'll
stop for an hour and drink a little bit
then they come right back to their local
bar yeah cuz their local bars you know
the locals are there yeah that's what
everybody they know and stuff right we
see y'all as Invaders
we live there
you well I think yeah like a lot of
people in day because like I said I grew
up in Dayton I was born there so I
wasn't a biker or nothing my dad kind of
was for a little bit
but um let me see oh uh Gabriel
Gabrielle says uh hey I love you guys we
love you too thank you and uh Karen also
says hi I love you guys she's the one
that's watching the the baby okay yeah
yeah she's been here before Gabrielle
sounds familiar yeah Gabrielle Marie
yeah we I've seen the name in the chat
before yeah we're all we're all friends
here in the chat yeah uh yeah buac says
hell yeah I'm excited to meet you guys
my wife has been checking out your
content too she loves the topics who
said this buac oh buac okay listen to
what I'm telling you hold on I'm going
to go to all
messages yeah if she she's coming did he
say she was
coming um well I don't know he just said
my wife's been checking out the content
yeah yeah yeah and I think I said um I
put um in
the on patreon and [__] like that cuz
normally I would do a poll like for
whatever next week's topic is going to
be but I think I brought this up before
because um our listener mut has sent us
two books about this particular case
we're going to do a show about that like
next week so I didn't do a poll this
weekend but I'll go back to doing polls
next week I was like if you went to all
the trouble to send the books then I got
to read those and you know what I mean
soon as my in starts working this
[__] phone I just reset it it's it's
acting crazy I'm going to show uh I'm
going to show uh some of Zack bu's
[__] bikes and some of his riding
zombie morning says greetings from
Mexico love your movie reviews okay than
thank you very much thank you very much
yeah we got uh got a got a couple of
pretty important uh show fans from uh
Mexico namely KH of oon I've been
friends with him online for years now we
trade pictures of girls booties a lot
and it pisses our wives
off well as it would hey man it's a
Latino thing you know what I mean they
hey man you seen that ass I haven't seen
that the round is the fir yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a whole it's just a thing we
do growing up in Brazil it seeped into
me it's kind of like when you go in the
grocery store and like feel all the
melons and yeah melons yeah you know
what I mean it's that kind of
thing
yeah Zach uh bu Zach says no his wife's
not coming okay so well you know you you
boys are going to get in all kind of
trouble there in Daytona all kind of
trouble all right like I said I can come
up to I can come up to Oasis and hang
out for a little bit but I'm not driving
all the way to [__] Daytona [__] that
trying to find I'm from
there trying to find some cool
videos
Zach that's Zach's [__] 1190 I
believe that's that that's the one you
bought right
Zach I think that's 1190 I think it's a
bu 1190 yeah yeah it
is he's got he's got a little [__] I
creature on it got a little creature
yeah and he's got a um it's all carbon
that's like a carbon
Edition and uh it's that as a [__]
badass
bike and there he is riding
it see that's
yeah I got to get my camera set up I got
two action cams yeah you got all kind of
cameras I don't know why you
don't
yeah and uh bu Zac also has a uh a bule
um xb12
SS I got an xp9 SX and a XB uh 9R excuse
me
XB12R that I uh
converted into a a lightning bolt which
is the front of it is a is a r and the
back of it is a s you have to know the
the models know what I'm talking about
but it's it's a good
custom there's more
Zach looks like he's got the camera
mounted on the
rear I know it's on somebody's helmet
okay
yep where's he uh want to find is
uh is
SS let me um I need a pen cuz somebody
recommended something for a show I need
to write
down over here for a second there's Zach
on his SS those are fun man I got that
same bike it's just shorter in uh 1,000
CC's that's a 1,200 he's
got I got that same motor that 1200 in
my other
bike Jeffy art says love your in-depth
on Epstein that show did come out good
didn't it um have you thought of looking
into the Alex murdog case seems like a
lot to unpack with that whole family um
I have not but I'm going to write that
down and we will do a show about that
eventually but yeah I was like you know
I can't believe it took us that long to
do the show the fene show but well we
had other things on the list and people
were voting for other things yeah I mean
it came out good though I really like
how it came out I was worried because I
was like oh my God this is an enormous
[__] case and it's going to take five
[__] hours to talk about which it
almost kind of which it almost did that
show ended up being what four hours long
yeah but we we covered everything and we
pretty much used uh the official
information the official approved
information uh that way we couldn't
really get in any trouble I did throw in
my opinions and I think Jen threw in
some of her opinions of what it all was
I believe it was a very high-end
International in intelligence operation
to get dirt on people and to gain
control over science it look like
science is what they were targeting all
the universities and [__] Zach says the
new season of True Detective is out yeah
I saw that Jody Foster is the main
character and it takes place in Alaska
episode two comes out tonight I think
yeah I've been wanting to like start
that but see I thought they dropped it
all at once but I guess now everybody's
doing the thing where like in the old
days where where they would just do one
episode a week or whatever cuz I kind of
like to binge it you know I know a lot
of people don't but how many 1190 rs's
are there Zach there's less than uh 200
I think huh cuz I think I got I think
you need a 100 to to become homog or
whatever they call it I think there's I
think there's probably less than 200 of
them and then um it's a rare and
expensive motorcycle they're talking
about the subspecies movies which that's
um I really need to get into I really
like the first one but I don't think
I've seen any of the sequels I might
have seen the second one but like a long
time ago Zach said there's 135 of them
okay
yeah yeah Tammy said she has all the
subspecies movies we should probably
review at least the first one one of
these days because I don't think that
we've done any of the subspecies movies
and I really like the first one so you
know what I mean I think I brought it up
on my oh that's another thing I actually
finally finally finished editing my
history of horror movies video
today so I'm gonna give it a watch
tomorrow or at least like kind of go
through it and make sure I didn't [__]
anything up because it's long and it's
like complicated so it's like I'm not
really sure if something got [__] up
or misplaced or something like while I
was editing it so I'm going to kind of
like just make sure it's okay so I
should be able to like put it up
tomorrow it ended up being 2 hours and
11 minutes Y and I think it came out
good I think but you know what I mean I
try I worked really hard on it like I
said I've been talking about doing it I
was going to put it up on Halloween and
obviously that's did not not happen um
and then I was going to put it up on
Christmas then I was going to put it up
on New Year's and that didn't work
either but it's finally finally done I
think so
yeah um Danny says I just saw a decent
1972 made for TV thriller movie called
crawl space um yeah did we review that
wait clus kinsky is that the klus kinsky
one cuz I know that there's two movies
called that we reviewed the crawl space
that had clous kinsy in it which that
[__] is like just creepy and
everything you don't even he didn't have
to do anything he just like stands in
your movie and you're just like you know
what me he creepy yeah he's [__]
creepy [__] and like I heard he
wasn't that great of a person either you
know I still need to watch that [__]
documentary about him and verer Herzog
didn't didn't K Claus kinsky have some
questionable relationships with the
daughter or something wasn't that him
that's what I heard yeah that's what I
heard I think she did accuse him of that
later on which I mean I you know I I
don't know I wasn't there but it
wouldn't really surprise me all that
much you know what I mean he comes
across his like super super
creepy super
creepy but yeah we just I've been
wanting to watch the um the new True
Detective but maybe I'll just wait till
they're all out so I can watch them all
at once because like I said I like to
binge I like to just kind of put them on
and like leave them on and watch them
all night you know what I
mean but for some reason and I think we
brought this up before like on the last
Sidetrack show when we were talking
about you know Tom being in Mississippi
and stuff and so we got into that TV
show that
HGTV show um Hometown that was that set
in Laurel Mississippi where they like go
and renovate houses and stuff and it's
there's like eight seasons of it and
it's all on Max and we've just been
watching those those are great actually
I really I really like the um the couple
that does it it's like it's a married
couple and they basically just like you
know people are moving to the town to
Laurel Mississippi and they want an old
house so they you know show them the
houses and then they buy one and then
they renovate it yeah and man some of
the [__] actually the one we saw last
night which I think was from season one
or season two I think it's season two
they moved the house picked it up moved
it they picked it up and moved it cuz it
belonged to this girl like it belonged
to her great grandma I think my dad grew
up there my granddad grew up there I
think my great-grandfather grew up there
in Laurel Mississippi and then uh I was
there pretty much every summer of my
life until I was old enough to leave
home and go to the
Army and uh now my dad moved well he
moved to uh heidleberg which is only
like 14 miles outside there in a little
German Town he was the last white guy
there and [__] died it was a few
weeks back now and uh that's where I
picked up all my black
cousins because yeah
[__] they were taking care of my dad
they [__] took real good care like
all his neighbors and stuff yeah all the
neighbors and
um uh one of the uh um kha was uh his
main caregiver through the state
basically and she also she I think she
did some stuff at the hospital too and
she'd come and see him every day make
sure everything was was good and kha was
[__] great and her sister lived
across the street from my
dad um
Clarice she was she of the turkey necks
yeah she was the one that brought told
so many stories about Mississippi over
the [__] years on this channel people
think maybe I'm bullshitting no
everything I said you can see it right
there in that television
program
Hometown everything that I say it'll
eventually appear even the choc to
Indians will appear last time there was
a chalk talk girl and her [__]
husband they were the ones that moved
the house it was her grandmother great
grand Grand's house house yeah and she
inherited it and I guess they couldn't
keep it on that same land cuz someone
else had bought that land or something
like that so she wanted wanted to move
it um it C you know what they said it
cost 15 grand to move it I was like
that's kind it's not cheap obviously but
that was cheaper than I imagined that it
would be and then they spent um I think
70 no 85,000 like renovating it and it
looked fantastic when they were done
yeah like they always like the couple
they always they have a big crew and
everything too but they always do like a
really good job Laurel Mississippi is
like Mayberry it says it right there on
the beginning of that damn program
that's like May
yeah hadberg was black Mayberry yeah it
wasn't it wasn't black when I was a
little kid but all the white people died
and the young PE young white people
moved away and uh black people moved in
and it's um mostly like two parent
families and they got a really nice high
school there and it's like kind of in a
way going back in time it's like being
in the 1950s but imagine a parallel
universe 1950s where almost everybody is
black they're doing parades and you know
[__] um cheerleaders and football
teams small americ small town America
it's extremely just American as [__] no
crime uh just good country people they
tend to be Pious there a lot of churches
they go to church and
stuff and uh you know it's just a it's a
side of America America that you'll
never see on television that that
doesn't make money except for that show
yeah except for that show which has been
on for eight years yeah yeah it's been
all for years but I'm talking about when
you know that's they're not going to
make movies about that they're going to
consider that too
boring well I don't know they they have
made movies about that yeah not maybe
but you know what I mean it's just kind
of like I don't know I just really like
that show um I've always kind of liked
home renovation shows like where they
just take some kind of shitty and I
really like that they're trying to cuz
they're usually these houses are from
the early 20th century and they're
usually trying to like at least
modernize them obviously but they're
trying to like restore them to the way
that they would have looked back then um
you know so they're going back to the
original hardwood floors they're you
know doing the the
Craftsman uh color schemes and all that
kind of stuff which I think is really
cool so they you know they they always
do like a really good job on it and they
tell you like how much it costs and all
that other kind of stuff Zack says Tom's
going to love the new True Detective
because the writer director said she was
inspired by the thing when writing it
and she was a protege of guo Del Toro I
think too yeah I mean I liked all of
True Detective that I've seen so grur
says sorry to hear your dad died my mom
died a year ago this
week all right that's Clarissa's husband
is Joey trible that's their son and
that's in heidleberg I'm just going to
show you just what it's
like and I'll show you
should be a picture of Clarice
and
Joey but his son is like the most
popular guy in the high school he had
cool hair and [__] dreads tall about six
feet tall just kind of gave off that
damn Alpha energy his his dad was like
yeah all the girls are after him and I
said he needs money because when you get
out of high school man all your damn
[__] status gets reset to zero man
you're going to fight against the 30y
old he's like yeah I'm trying to get him
to go to Old Miss that's the university
there just don't knock any girls up what
I told him I told him that so you better
not get any girls pregnant around here
rap it son yeah fing cuz you you don't
want that yeah you don't want that mess
he considered my my dad to be his like
Uncle cuz my ever since he was a little
kid my dad take him out fishing and
stuff yeah yeah yeah did you hear what I
said grur said that he was was sorry
about your dad and said my mom died a
year ago this week yeah uh actually what
happened to my dad that was the best
place for him I mean he was sick he had
to go he did not like what condition he
was in yeah he he was ready to go he was
let me die he was yelling he wouldn't
say that around us but we weren't
visiting him he'd be calling out to the
nurses let me die damn it yeah he it's
like yeah was he wasn't having any fun
was he no he couldn't do what he wanted
to do anymore right i' say I can't blame
you like if I was just like bad and
couldn't do anything anymore like
couldn't see couldn't hear Couldn't
Write couldn't do anything like that he
had L cancer and his heart was failing
and he had real bad diabetes he was
lucky to live to 77 that's a full life
that's that's within life expect I mean
considering the southern diet yeah of
his generation and considering all of
the medical issues that he had yeah I'm
actually quite surprised that he lived
that along yeah because like I said when
he got the bypass the triple bypass I
wasn't sure he was going to make it then
I didn't think he was going to make make
it then yeah and that was that was a few
years ago yeah so but he pulled right
through that for and then he was okay
for a couple years and then he just
started declining yeah and he was just
every time Tom would call him he'd be
like he just didn't feel good and he
couldn't do anything and you know that's
them that's
Joey and that's Clarice and that's their
son I forgot what his name was I just
met him that one time one with the cool
hair it was like the uh getting all the
girls getting all the girls getting all
the girls
yeah
yeah it's been I mean I think I sat
on and Joey is a Mason he's in a masonic
lodge there and he's also in the
Army see trying to see I could get it
down you keep talking oh well no because
then you'll all right no it's
fine then you'll just like interrupt and
I'll have to go over there and you know
what I mean there he is there's Joe
there's Joe in his
uniform sorry In First Class
yeah yeah what I was going to say was
that you know it hasn't been a
great couple months I guess I mean your
dad died my stepdad died a couple days
ago my grandma died about a month ago
month and a half something like that my
uncle died one of my uncles I have a lot
of them but one of my uncles died and
that was only a week or two after my
grandma died so you know how hasn't been
too fun I'm just going to um I'm not
real sure about I might go see my mom I
want you to come with me though cuz I
don't like driving all she lives out in
the middle of nowhere like in the Okala
national forest and there's no cell
service or the cell service out there is
like real spotty so I'm not a big fan of
like driving out there by myself in that
car because if something happens I'll be
out in the middle of nowhere and I'll
get murdered so when are we doing this I
don't know okay I don't know I don't
know what's going on my sister's coming
down from Atlanta on Sunday
and she's going to stay there for a week
I think but cuz like I said she can work
remotely but so I might just go like one
day and like hang I'm not going to stay
over or anything but we'll see how it
goes cuz like I said she kind of lives
out in the middle of nowhere and I don't
know I don't know what's G to happen now
you
know Danny says that crawl space film
stars wait a minute the old priest from
The Sentinel yeah that was a good movie
and the balloon knot inspector from the
English film let sleeping corpses lie oh
yeah [__] I haven't seen that in a long
time AKA living dead at the Manchester
morg yeah I feel like I think I used to
have that on VHS a long time ago but I
don't know what happened to it I haven't
seen that since I was very
young um murder Hornets talking about uh
you getting pegged again that's his
fanty yeah he wants to buy that video
but he don't want to [__] pay for it
you want that's all these you got these
dudes want to come off and jerk off on
me but then they want they want they
don't want to pay
see I'm not that kind of hoe I'm a hoe
I'm a hoe for pay well I mean yeah if
you're going to do that do that you have
to pay at least we need money and I'm
talking motorcycle level money yeah yeah
motor talking about I'm not
cheap
I'm
sounds it's like he's like we're
drinking Coke and uh coke and rum R rum
and coke and uh I like it I'm kind of
getting a taste for it got that bardi
silver in there yeah we were changing it
up it's kind of give it a nice smooth
and buttery taste I don't know where
you're getting buttery but okay it's got
kind of a buttery taste the back end of
that is nice and nice
and nice and Rich almost like a vanilla
flavor or something yeah I'm getting
vanilla I'm really getting buttery well
that's not I mean like buttery it's just
really funny
because like 20 minutes before the show
started like Tom's like we don't have
enough booze and I was like oh [__] cuz
I went in and made a drink and I was
like Ah that's probably enough enough
and I didn't really think about it he's
like no that's not enough Friday show we
drink about a third of a box like I'm
going
to we'll drink a half a fifth of booze
it's Friday night and we're not going
out we're not going anywhere tonight so
you know Tom's been out on his
motorcycle today for hours and hours
yeah tooling around yeah well no I
stopped too I stopped off at uh
Starbucks listen to a [__] couple
heavy metal albums and
[__] Zack says by the way I was trying
to pick Tom's brains earlier I have an
idea for a horror script about a federal
bureau that investigates the Paranormal
see I kind of like that idea I know you
sent me the that script and I haven't
had time to read it yet but I will read
it I promise I got to read those two
books too I got to do that this weekend
maybe or early next
week but yeah I don't know
um okay is that the okay I'm not going
to say anything I'm not going to say
anything is that what nothing nothing
nothing nothing must be nice to
ride well I mean where's he at where
must be up north yeah it's quite cold
yeah he's up north yeah it's and he went
out Wednesday Wednesday it was actually
coldish I think it was in the 40s yeah I
just put my inner jacket liner on and
went out yeah cuz I asked him I'm like
are you freezing your balls off or what
and only gets cold is your knuckles yeah
he's like no it wasn't too bad oh he's
in Indiana yeah okay yeah that's still
pretty North though but today I think it
was when you left 70 it was yeah it was
about
70° but it got it's kind of cold now but
coldish you can pretty much ride all
year around
here yeah it never gets I mean unless it
unless it's like pouring down rain which
it does that a lot in summer it rains
almost every day yeah it pretty much
matter like and it rains hard like every
day yeah not for long yeah it's usually
like quick but like I said it's kind of
dangerous cuz the roads are wet and
whatnot but other than that been Zack
I've been riding before well I see it
coming a wall of black water gray water
like oh like oh [__] oh [__] I'll slow
down about 15 and all the cars are
slowing down boom it's like oh [__] it's
like something out a damn Fury Road
remember how the damn wall of sand hit
them it's like that that's why when I
saw that in the movie I was just kind of
like oh so like Florida and Su yeah and
then the except water the wind and the
wind comes in and it'll blow in sideways
and blow up I've been in been in rain so
weird that the water's falling but the
wind is blowing up and some of the some
of the wind is some of the water is
going up so I guess there's like little
edies in there weird [__] it doesn't
last for long
but man and during the summer too like I
was driving back from Daytona and it
seemed like there would be a horrible
storm like every day like right when I
was driving home and it's like I'd be on
92 like which is kind of this shitty
Highway and it would just be like white
out like the rain and [__] was so heavy
that you literally could not see where
you were yeah when that wall of water
hits you your visibility is like 5T and
I was just kind so I'd slow down to like
10 miles an hour and be like hopefully
no one Rams into the cuz it's like I
can't see the lines in the road I don't
even know if I'm on the road um I can't
see anybody I I just get off the road go
go into the bicycle lane if there's one
there and just stop yeah I mean that's
the best thing to do and you just put up
with it it's few minutes later it starts
to lighten up it does that like pretty
much every day yeah like I said it
doesn't last that long but it's still
like really scary because a lot of times
it'll just come up like real sudden yeah
and it doesn't matter how good your gear
is you're just soing wet to the Bone
well yeah you can't avoid it can't avoid
it
yeah let's
see Danny says y'all should check out
the 2009 film Night of the Living Dead
reanimated cuz it's got your boy jeffre
comes in it just saying I think that
might be one of the only Jeffrey comes
movies that I have not seen not the
Living Dead reanimated yeah yeah you're
going to see that yeah that's yeah yeah
yeah I remember they did yeah I remember
that coming out I don't think I saw it
though we getting a lot of people in
here for a Sunday who's here it's a
Friday it's not Friday excuse me he
doesn't know what it is no I met Friday
he doesn't know what it is went sound
off if you he murder Hornet said little
mover little is little mover here she
used to show up she used to show up on
Fridays haven't seen her in a while
murder Hornet said um what is that Haze
killer or HZ killer I can't really see
that good T scop showing up that's a
catfish account Tila and who I don't
think she was a catfish that was too
long to be
catfish Sandra she's probably just doing
other [__] yeah or maybe we said
something that made him mad I don't know
I think I think Sandra got mad when I
was talking about
Germany I don't see why she didn't she
didn't seem like the kind of person that
would get mad about that kind of stuff I
taught her all about peanut butter she
started eating pean peanut but good
peanut butter in Germany they
tell said she was getting fat on Peanut
Butter when SRA was here she I loved it
because she would always change her
screen name like every single time like
for the chat and they were always like
super funny it had to do with something
I said the show before yeah then it
usually had something to do with
something that's off from the past show
so I would see I would see her name and
I just be like crack up because I like
oh yeah that's
funny yeah Danny said it's a sequel to
nighted living 3D yeah yeah
yeah Zach says you put Sandra in a
peanut butter coma maybe that's what
happened yeah yeah Danny said maybe she
overdosed yeah are you guys Happy
Now peanut Butter's so good I was saying
you're
G I was I was saying you can eat that
[__] remember I was telling her that she
how how voluptuous it would make
her she came out and said she was skinny
fat and flat flat chested and skinny fat
I don't think Peanut Butter King you
biger I said yeah well just keep eating
peanut butter you'll get voluptious I
don't think that's how it
works all depends on where your where
your fat cells are you know you can eat
all you want like some people are really
lucky and like they eat a lot and it
just all goes to their boobs in their
ass but I'm not one of those people
unfortunately so you know what I mean
yeah depends it depends depends on what
gear you're on well yeah that you yeah
and what your R workout routine is doing
yeah I mean you know I could get you
shaped crazy man given enough
time I don't want to be crazy shaped
yeah well you might need some body
filler like some of those girls do just
[__] just start dropping it down into
your ass and you just [__] get huge
you're not going to do that Tom I I know
that he's going to come to me and be
like I can do that all right I can't do
it I've done all the research on how to
do it I'm not going to leave you do that
yeah no way I already let you pierce my
nipples that's those girls are doing
Brazilian butt lift now they re they're
um when you see those big fine chicks
they they they got big tits and ass but
they have skinny waist it's because
they've moved the waist fat to the
ass uh you know a lot of times they have
implants too Brazilian
buttlift but the thing is is
that I could do it but I had to buy the
equipment to do it there's a fat
Transfer
Machine it's like a vacuum cleaner yeah
I know I've seen it sucks you need a big
old Long Rod and it's sharp on the
inside I've seen them I've seen them do
it I've seen them do it too you have to
make about a quarter inch decision to
get the [__] probe in there and
here's the thing people I got friends
who are doctors I grew up with them
there's nothing special to any that [__]
A lot of it has to do with balls that's
why I saying had the other guy he
learned how to do it impr prison and
faked being a [__] surgeon and got a
job at a [__]
hospital where they he just lied his way
into being a doctor and he was a good
doctor he did [__] hundreds of
surgeries before they caught him so this
dude is not even a doctor he just read
about
it well we were saying this before I
said yeah you can learn to do anything
because obviously if someone learn to do
it then that's the same way that they do
it but I will admit that at least
doctors they get to like practice on
corpses and [__] yeah but just you know
I [__] did vivisection and dis SE in
high school and [__] I'm real good
with knives and Butchery and I've cut a
lot of deer apart you know it's you get
flashh is
flesh dealing with but here's the here's
the
thing here's the real problem here's the
reason why I don't [__] do medical
malpractice and just saying oh I'm going
to do
this you have to have on hand the
correct drugs and you have to know the
procedures if anything goes wrong yeah
that's what I mean that's really where
the [__] problem is because it's like
you know nine times out of 10 it would
probably be fine there's always this
chance where the the patient has some
kind of reaction to blood loss or or
drug reaction and you got to know your
[__] yeah you don't have [__] on hand
you're right now one thing that
could cause one that could save you a
lot of problems here in the United
States they like to do [__] under
general anesthesia which is very
dangerous you're putting somebody
under they're damn near that damn near
kills them the differences in doses
between death and and life are very slim
with with general
anesthesia in the third world they'll do
those procedures under local
anesthesia it's a lot cheaper the
person's awake
though but you know in places like
Brazil you just grin and bear it you
just put a [__] privacy Shield so the
victim can't see what you're doing not
the victim but that's yeah it's
interesting that you use that
terminology doesn't it so uh so the
victim can't see what's happening they
can't feel anything so the patient but
the thing is is they can hear it yeah
see I think and they could probably and
they could probably smell it and I I
don't know if I be uh and the doctors
are saying oh [__] can you hand me that
over there
okay okay so you have to have oh damn it
yeah yeah that's not supposed to happen
so be like what they're trying to do is
they're trying to give the person a
smooth [__] sit a smooth um [__]
a smooth [__] what do you call it
WorryFree [__] experience they W they
wake up and it's done you know what I
mean I would rather have that honestly
yeah because it's like if you if they
put you under and you die like you don't
know any different you know what I mean
local but the thing is is that a lot of
times from my understanding depending on
what the procedure
is the biggest risk is not the is not
the surgical procedure it's the
anesthesia that's really I've heard that
as well that's really the [__]
dangerous part um that's why an
anesthesiologist makes so much [__]
money it's going to cost you about a
grand just to go under well yeah it's a
tricky [__] yeah I've only been under
it you go to Thailand and they [__]
it's $25 just to [__] numb the area
and they'll go to work on it you
know so when you're talking about
economy just numb the area I mean I've
been under general anesthesia one time
in my whole life um yeah and it worked
good I mean you know yeah I didn't
remember a [__] thing yeah when you
woke up and you were talking to me and
you didn't even you didn't even remember
I remember that until later yeah like I
said the first thing I remember I
remember waking up in the recovery room
and being freezing cold and I think I
asked for a blanket did I ask for a
blanket yeah you were cold I mean I had
a blanket on me but I was like can I
have another one cuz I was freezing my
ass off now they said that that was
going to happen they were like you know
wear something warm wear socks all this
other kind of stuff cuz you're going to
be real cold um but I woke up and I was
like Jesus [__] Christ it's like they
weren't kidding um but after that it was
I don't remember talking to you I don't
remember any of that like I remember
kind of waking up in the chair thing
like the recliner thing and being
freezing cold and asking for a blanket
and then I remember you walking me to
the car yeah and then I remember you
sitting me up in the bed at home and
giving me a sandwich yeah you recovered
[__] so quickly man it
was my first wife [__] it took her a
[__] week just to [__] get out of
the bed man from that [__] but it didn't
bother you as much it hurt but it didn't
it's cuz you already had big boots it
only hurt when I woke up I was just kind
of like a [__] that sucks but it's just
like after a few hours I was like eh
it's not that bad Jen had big
boobs lost a bunch of weight [__] got
implants to [__] get the boobs fill
them back up fill them back up cuz they
kind of deflet yeah and it it it work CU
I lost like 90 lbs yeah and it it
[__] worked like a charm and uh she
shook it off like it was nothing my
first first wife was I didn't even take
all the painkillers no my first wife was
like maybe 100 lb [__] 5
foot three or four and went from totally
flat to a large decup in about [__]
an hour and she said it was she said it
was like having two or three guys
standing on her chest she could barely
[__] breathe I mean that's I had to
keep her knocked out for about two or
three days yeah and I was just taking
care of her and [__] keeping her
[__] knocked out
and but it took weeks for her to kind of
[__] Shake It Off she looked great
though when she got out when she got up
though but um yeah
you I was ready for that ordeal when she
went through it's like the next day
she's walking around like nothing I even
went I even went to work the next day I
drove they told me not to they said well
you probably won't be able to drive a
car and nothing like that but the next
day I'm pretty sure I went to work yeah
she was like I don't feel this is no big
deal she's like it's all right yeah and
I don't even think I took I to I took a
couple of the painkillers yeah you
didn't take them all no I didn't you
said I don't need that no I was all
right like I said it hurt but it was it
was just like kind of achy that's all it
was and I'm just like eh yeah well no
that's just traumatic for a girl that
doesn't have any breast material well
and like I said I have a pretty high
pain threshold yeah
overall yeah although the nipple
piercing that was another yeah that was
word I that another I don't think I'd do
that again uh yeah I don't I don't think
you should
but see that's why came out they look
great though they do look great and you
did a good job I'm just saying that
that's kind of what I was saying about
the whole medical thing is that you know
reading about it in a book and like
actually doing it are two different
things you know what I'm saying so
that's why I kind of trust like maybe
people that have been in medical school
and have like practiced on dead bodies
and stuff like that because at least
they've done it like to a dead person
that couldn't you know what I mean so
cuz you were just kind of like you read
about it you had all the stuff and you
did it right yeah but but you were it
felt you didn't really know exactly what
it felt like I had no idea how tough and
how elastic nipple material is I thought
it was going to be like cuz I I put
needles in myself all the time [__]
taking injections and I just using right
but those are little bigger yeah but I
can use a big gauge needle too I start
off the little ones and then you go up
with a bigger gauge needle in behind it
to push a bar through and that it's just
uh but the thing is is that I didn't
realize when you're pushing it through
that through that nipple material it's
crackling and crunching the sound it
made was really something it's like I
was going through bone man and I think
Tom like I was having a hard time but I
think Tom was also having a hard time
cuz he was like oh no oh [__] and once I
got one done I couldn't leave the other
one undone I know she went through like
a [__] tribal right of passage this
chick could take some [__] pain and
and then she's like you want me to do it
to you and I was like [__] no [__] I was
like oh you made not after seeing that
[__] they look great though they do look
after seeing after [__] actually
seeing feeling what that felt like to go
through there and that's a big needle
yeah a big large yeah it crackled and
popped all the way through there yeah
well like I said babies pull on that
with their little tooths and stuff but I
just had I just had to [__] grin and
Barett and get through it you know what
I mean mentally I was kind of like going
oh [__] what what am I doing to this
poor woman yeah well I knew what I was
doing I just didn't realize it was going
to feel that way yeah I thought it would
just be like going through regular meat
right I go through muscle all the time
no it's not it's more like going through
rubber yeah hard rubber that cracks and
Pops yeah and uh I was disturbed by how
it felt cuz I had I had her nipp I'm
feeling it going through and I'm feeling
that [__] crack and pop and it took it
took an amazing amount of pressure much
more than I thought I thought it would
just slip through no it took a lot of
pressure well I almost fainted cuz I
told you it's like you have to stop
because I'm going to black out yeah um
because because I'll do that um actually
I blacked out when you were just
changing the Rings one time too yeah so
now like whenever he changes the Rings I
have to lay down cuz if I'm standing up
I'll just I'll black out I wish I could
show you guys a picture but we can't I
got pictures of them they look good
they're some of yall are probably
they're in deep set and they're big bars
deep set and they're straight and the
one she's got in now it's a deep bar
with a [__] Crescent Moon kind of
things that hangs underne little be like
pearly beads on this these cute little
slave girl [__] things they're really
nice I do like them but like I said holy
[__] that was one of the most painful
things that I've ever
experienced but like I said it's funny
because like it hurt but I I was almost
kind of like I think Tom was more
freaked out than I was I was freaked out
too I knew it was going to hurt I knew
but I think he was more freaked out
because he he wasn't expecting it to
happen like that and I'm just sitting
there going it's like bro I'm going to
pass out like my vision started going
black around the edges like cuz I have
have I have super super low um blood
pressure like I always have done it's
just I have really low blood pressure so
basically I can just like stand up too
fast and I'll be just like you know what
I mean and like I'm going to pass out so
anything like that where there's some
kind of like intense pain or injury or
something like that I'm just like yep
I'm going to black out so I'm just going
to at least have to lay down so the
first time he did it I was like sitting
up on the weight
machine and I was just kind of like um I
was like we can't do it like this
because you know I I was going to black
out but I didn't but I felt like I was
going to so the second one I had to like
lay down on my back and it was better
you know what I mean like it still was
horrible and it hurt but it was better
like I wasn't didn't feel like I was
going to pass out you know what I mean
um oh my God all right what are you guys
talking about all right um Zach says
gingers are known for having a higher
than normal pain tolerance why do you
think they need more anesthetic to go
under yeah I'm not actually sure how
many how much anesthetic they gave me
when I had my
surgery um cuz I haven't had I'm
naturally a red head but I haven't had
naturally red hair in a very very long
time like I started dying it black I
don't even remember when I started dying
black like a long time ago so I'm not
sure if they knew but the anesthetic
they gave me like worked really good I
didn't remember a [__] thing they
gave me the thing and they were just
like you know they did the count
backwards from 100 thing and I think I
only got to 98 and I was like yeah you
were out instantly and then the next
thing that I remembered was waking up in
the chair being like why am I why am I
so cold get me another blanket this is
not working okay go through comments
let's see what's going on Joseph says
speaking of anesthesia remember the
movie Coma yeah did we we reviewed that
we did that Michael kryon would it yeah
yeah yeah yeah I like that movie
actually yeah those movies were kind of
um rob levenson a fan of the show sent
me a bunch of Michael kryon movies we
reviewed them um I'm pretty sure we did
coma yeah I think we did coma I think we
did it but
uh those the movies the screenplays I
think he wrote books isn't that where he
started he wrot books he wrote Jurassic
Park yeah yeah he wrote a bunch of [__]
yeah his books were always like
futuristic for the time yeah he was
rolling well wasn't isn't he did West
world wasn't he a doctor I think he I
think he was I think he was a doctor he
did Westworld yeah that's right I think
he did runaway didn't he uh you know
maybe yeah we reviewed that with uh Tom
C Tom Cel yeah I think so where he's
fighting
robots oh and jeene Simmons is in that
too yeah maybe he did that one I'm not
sure I'd have to look it up I can't
remember jeene Simmons was in it he was
the one that had the Sleep gun yeah
that's right wasn't that that same movie
that's a pretty it's it's cheesy but
it's like I have kind of a fondness for
it though that movie yeah and uh Jean
Simmons actually did a pretty good job
as a villain yeah he was actually
surprisingly good in it yeah and he was
working he was uh basically kind of like
a Hitman for a big powerful high-tech
Corporation and and they gave him this
[__]
gun that if he pointed it at you and you
happened to be looking at him it would
flash some kind of a invisible light or
a light in a certain pattern that would
cause your brain to malfunction for a
few seconds and then from your point of
view it was like there was a lapse in
time so you're like wait hold on you
keep blacking out right so it from your
point of view it's like people were
disappearing and reappearing yeah yeah
it was it was it was a pretty good
thinking Michael kryon thought that
something like that could exist yeah
maybe theoretically they thought it
could exist it doesn't though Jeff Ard
said I believe Michael kryon had a PhD
in medicine yeah I thought he did I
didn't know if he was a practicing
physician but I knew he had a degree in
that it's like he also wrote The
Andromeda Strain thata St yeah that was
another good one I think we reviewed
that one too yeah and he did the one
where they were using a [__]
supercomputer to do like algorithms to
find out what's the best facial
proportions for some for women remember
that to looker yeah and they use them to
sell products on the on the market I
mean which
that's kind of well that's going on now
that was like way ahead of its time yeah
a where AI is generating like the
perfect the perfect woman what they look
like and then it turns out that they got
some of these AI fake only fans Bots or
whatever they are they're making like
$35,000 a [__] month and that's not a
girl it's a [__] robot dudes don't
even know they could do video and
everything well we were watching that um
that video on Wang's Channel about that
Instagram account with the supposedly
hot Asian girl that was like super into
motorcycles and stuff it dud and then
you found out later that it was like an
old dude like a middle-aged dude and he
was just using a filter to make him look
like a pretty girl because he was like
well nobody seemed to give a [__] like
when it was just like an old dude
talking about motorcycles and stuff when
it was like a hot young chick then
everybody was into it yeah and the weird
thing about it though is that after
everybody found out they were okay with
it they still liked him they were like
well well because they're like well it
was still his personality and it was
still his you know what I mean it was
just his face that was different so it's
like so a lot of people got into his
personality so he didn't lose followers
or anything they're like ah it's it's
all right that's funny but you know it's
a fascinating story actually I can't
remember what his name is now they got
guys that are saying that you know well
these robots will uh [__] destroy and
replace all these only fans models they
won't they won't because a simp is going
to try to find a real woman all right
and um once it gets out that some of
these accounts are Bots they just look
too good to be true or whatever they're
they're going to lose interest in that
they're gonna yeah I'm not to find super
worried about it because it's well I why
would I worry about it I don't think
that's I don't we don't do like I and I
don't have any dog in that fight anyway
yeah we saw video but we're not doing
what the only fans models do yeah which
is that's they get keeping dudes and
keeping simps and bullpens and [__]
what's called a bullpen or basically a
cell they don't know what's going on and
trying to milk them for money um AI is
better at that really than a than a lot
of women because the AI has the time
women don't yeah no [__] we have other
things to do you know they don't care
about
[Laughter]
the
but you know I I've I listen to the
manosphere stuff and there's a lot of
good stuff about the red pill what they
call Red Pill movement there are certain
aspects of it that that I I like I wish
I'd had that when I was younger but some
of the [__] that they talk
about uh they're blowing it out of
[__] proportion okay like they're
real down on only fans
models why because they can't get them
no they just think it's destroying the
dating scene or what it it's not okay
most of the only fans most of those only
fans girls make under or around $300 a
month they only have a few dozen
subscribers yeah that's a lot of people
that do that they don't make a living
off that it's just like a side side cash
yeah and you go well I would never sell
my soul for $300 yes you would okay I
mean if you need $300 if you were a
single woman you probably need yeah you
do a lot for $300 if you were a single
woman maybe you're a single mom too
living in a small apartment somewhere or
you're living out in the middle of
nowhere working at a little Greers or
something out in the middle of
Mississippi a little bit grocery store
$300 is a big [__] that's a lot of
money that's a lot of
money you can buy your kids food for
that yeah that's enough money to make
rent help you make rent and all they're
doing is maybe talking to about a
hundred guys off and on and they're
working alone in their homes yeah taking
pictures like I said I would never be
Grudge because it's just kind kind of
like I don't get I don't get where
people get off judging people for that
yeah I just don't well okay some of the
[__] they really they're not complaining
about that they're complaining about the
top top girls and the top top girls are
really actually more porn stars than
anything else they're having sex with
other people on their profil sure all
right some of them are married and
they're having sex with other people
which then they that that is kind of
strange when you think about it well if
if they know about it it's not that
strange but yeah a lot of them know
about it some of them might probably
don't but okay well that's [__] up but
other than that if the husband doesn't
care that's them you know I mean yeah
that's it's nothing to do with me that's
their relationship if that works out for
them who am I to tell them like that's
not right right you know what I mean
like I said I wouldn't do that but so
some of these guys are thinking well
because of this only fan all women are
going to become only fans model no they
won't oh come on now no they can't
really believe that are they really that
dumb they're young these are guys in
their
20s is what you're saying yeah a lot of
these guys that are saying this are in
their 20s and they don't really I feel
like dudes that young and that have that
proclivity not all young dudes are
idiots but it's like that have that
mindset they really they get [__] over
by one woman and suddenly all women
women are demons it's just it's the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen the
girls do at that age do it too that's
what I mean like it just do it too
everybody just kind of does that yeah
when you're when you're in your 20s
you're anot you can't like everybody's
different yeah you know you get [__]
over by one person of whatever gender or
whatever that doesn't mean that
everybody of that same gender everybody
that looks like that is going to [__]
you over that's ridiculous yeah Jesus
Christ yeah I mean maybe it's easy for
me to say cuz I'm old but you know what
I mean yeah I don't think I even thought
like that when I was a kid though like
when I was younger I don't remember
thinking like that when I was a kid
young guys are like oh this dude [__]
me over so all dudes are bad I never
thought that young young guys are
in they don't have a whole lot of
experience they're when you're in your
20s man the odds are against you because
you just can't compete against guys in
their 30s and 40s they're making all the
money so the girls your age are all
going out guys that are much
older so you're kind of left
out that's part of the problem right
there that that they're that then they
see this only fan stuff and maybe they
can't do that or they think that that's
competition against them it's a
temporary situation being in your 20s
yeah it it uh it kind of sucks for
everybody to be honest yeah and and by
the time you get into your
40s you look back at the [__] you
thought when you were in your 20s you're
like man I didn't know what the [__] I
was worried about man what the [__] was
I talking about you know you'll be
embarrassed yeah everyone is yeah that's
just how it
works I did less dumb [__] in my teens
and 20s than most people probably but I
still did dumb [__] and I thought dumb
[__]
but but like I said everybody does
that's just kind of the nature of the
Beast I guess Zach says oh I've seen
your piercings Jen thanks to Tom and it
kind of felt like when you see your mom
naked by
accident yeah I showed him I showed him
to [__] Zach and says that that was
right after I did right after I did him
he was very
proud like yeah
yeah he sent him to lots of people I
don't need I I don't know who he said he
sends he sends [__] yeah all the time I
don't know well he came he came back
from Oasis Wednesday and he said that he
had showed Amy the bartender that video
that of me blowing you yeah she loved it
yeah of course she's like God I'm
getting hot I don't really care
but you tell
Jen she's gonna that I live right across
the street y'all I ain't got nothing to
do she's she's gonna knock on the door
one day with like a with like a 12pack
of beer or something oh my God she's a
content creator too though yeah she does
I'm showing it to although like I said
cuz you saw some video that she had done
yeah with somebody like a threesome type
thing but that was like a long time ago
yeah it was probably from about five six
years she did it yeah she looked the
same though but she just she wants to
get involved she wants to get involved
oh she's bad she's bad she's bad we
haven't streamed in a while actually no
but we probably should yeah I mean I
just haven't really had time but for
those you who don't know what we're
talking about we do do a little bit of
stream mate on the side we were doing it
for a while man it [__] gets boring
because a lot of it's just
waiting and when when money's coming
from other directions we we'll jump on
that instead of going stream it stream
it yeah because you never know how much
money you're going to make like on a
good day like you might have a really
good day and like make a bunch of money
and then another day it's like nobody's
in there like dead yeah so it's like you
never really know and you kind of just
have to kind of sit around and and wait
so yeah and you feel like a hoe [__]
sitting out on the [__] Street with
the cars going by yeah you hey
yeah you know what I mean it is kind of
like that it's a little bit I don't want
to say it's demeaning it's I don't think
it's demeaning well maybe it is a little
bit just gets kind of boring it is kind
it's mostly just boring to be honest
because it's like sometimes it's there's
hardly anybody yeah in there you're just
sitting in there waiting for somebody to
[__] go hey what you guys doing they
won't talk to you A lot of them will
just come in and look for a second then
they leave yeah that's what happens like
95% of the time it's like people just
pop in cuz they're going in everybody's
yeah streams and seeing what's going on
it's like hey is anybody doing anything
that I can watch for free yeah you know
what I mean cuz some people will yeah we
try not to but you know what I mean yeah
they got dudes down South America got
people down in South America that are
just doing this [__] for free out in
public just for tips yeah which I don't
know maybe that's a good strategy I'm
not really sure I don't think it I don't
think it is not on that platform because
it's because in places like Venezuela
and [__] [__] $30 is a lot of money
yeah that's nothing here not so much
here
yeah I probably need another all right
you probably need another one too yours
is almost empty yeah Jeffy Ard said it's
a historical joke when mankind makes
huge leavs in science they find a way to
use it for sex yeah they do I mean I
don't know I can't be too mad about it
but that does seem to happen doesn't it
and I I feel
like um porn is always kind of on the
Vanguard of whatever the new technology
is I mean I kind of feel like they were
on the Vanguard of like home VHS when
that whole thing started um you know
they the POR producers were able to see
like where which way the wind was
blowing like how the technology was
going and they just like jumped right on
that um same thing with the internet
same thing with the live streaming same
thing with all of that I kind of feel
like porn was there first they
just people that produce that seem to
like really know they really keep up
with uh Trends and [__] like that and
technology and they just jump right on
the newest thing that comes out so I
don't know if that's still true but I do
kind of feel like for a long time they
were like on the Vanguard of
everything Tammy says she's saving as
far as fast as I can for a
motorcycle you guys really really want
to see this we would want to see this I
want to do it too but like I said I
wouldn't do anything that he didn't want
me to do because that's not cool
but you know he said he he said without
any prompting for me that for motorcycle
money he would do it so we'll see we'll
hold him to that if somebody can come up
with it when's that a24 Civil War movie
coming out um I don't know I thought it
no I thought it was out already but no
we we got to go see that [__] tomorrow
we'll go to the I don't well maybe it's
not I don't maybe it's not go go to the
Chinese [__] buffet and then go watch
the dam go the Chinese
buffet I still want to see I want to see
that Nas ferazzi movie but I don't think
that's coming out until [__] December
man I just saw I don't think it's coming
out till the till
December yeah
it's I don't know like um there's been a
lot of [__] about AI especially like in
my line of work which is not porn it's
graphic
design and because of AI like um you
know uh a lot of stuff is easy like a
lot of artists get upset like I know
some artists that are like really upset
about it because they're just kind of
like nobody wants to pay artists anymore
for original artwork when you can just
go on a $10 app and make this crazy
looking artwork um so I get that but I
don't know I don't know how this [__] is
going to shake out I've been
experimenting with it myself it's just
like I I just think it's interesting I
don't use it for anything particularly
except like I said I use it for
thumbnails and stuff like that because I
don't have time to do original artwork
for every single thumbnail or anything
like the thumbnail for this like with
the three cats with the
with the um like oldfashioned outfits on
I was just like I just made that in Ai
and I thought it was funny so that's
what I used but I can see how you know
artists and like I said you know I've
seen this [__] happen too where I think
like you know some clubs I might have
done flyers for and stuff like that are
just using AI [__] now instead of like
hiring somebody you know to do something
because it's you know it's cheaper so I
can see that but I don't know I don't
see how it's all going to work out I
don't know if it's ever going to get to
a
point because you know like Tom was
saying about the Bots are like the you
know fake women on only
fans I mean will it get to a point
where you know they're so good that you
can't tell the difference and then will
there be like a backlash because people
are like oh well you know we know they
we know they're not real and stuff like
that and then at some point will the AI
be like well we have to put in like
imperfections what they'll do is they'll
have
platforms that will require you to be a
human
being that's what
they I don't know I'm I'm just not
really all that
bothered that that type of client wants
to interact with a real human being yeah
and I mean there's always going to be
some people that would rather have the
AI that would rather have the AI or you
know there's already dudes that have
like you know married sex dolls and
stuff like that ridiculous yeah so you
know but that I mean that's pretty
fringe Zack sent us something what's up
Zack thank you very
much no that's that's gay Zack gay Zack
okay sent Tom a pick of a ginger dude I
banged last month it's not a nude tell
me he doesn't have the best hair you've
ever seen can I show him on the show
wait he said it's not nude can I show
him on the show well I don't know I
wouldn't if I were you because see what
we don't know who that person is see
what
Zach's Z for some reason Zach's got me
cruising dudes with him okay I love that
I love
that I love I love the I love the
bisexual action oh yeah I think he s me
that picture too that is some fabulous
hair can I what did he say what did he
say no can't show I don't care he
doesn't I don't care he doesn't either
okay Hees that's Zach's little boyfriend
nice yeah okay I like the smirk yeah
look at that [__] hair man he's that
is some ni he's like some [__] he have
like some nice like hair products he's
is the expensive he looks like one of
them dudes off the [__] romance novel
covers he does actually yeah all he
needs is
someo he needs some frilly [__] Jabo
around his neck in a [__] 1700s
outfit like clutch to this woman or
another dude like you know up like that
like can't believe with with a castle in
the background yeah yeah castle in the
background I could see it loves
throbbing instead of a woman swoo in in
his arms got Zach that's
yeah well sorry I just thought of I was
I was thinking of the Mystery Science
Theater joke about the romance novel
what was it called Love's throbbing
Gondola or something like that uh but
yes that's what I was
thinking love Jeff says [__] Jeffy
says that's a gorgeous man it it's nice
yeah yep like I said he's he obviously
uses like some really good expensive
product for that it's nice
color my hair is not that it's actually
orer my hair is orer than that it's
slightly lighter and oranger mine's like
um copper colored like a
penny like a new Penny that's what color
my hair is naturally although it's
probably gray now I wouldn't know been a
long time since we've seen your hair
been a long time since I've seen my
natural hair color when I'm shaving the
side of your head it just looks kind of
gray gray yeah that's I mean so it's
probably I mean I think just the roots
are gray yeah if I let it grow out
completely it would probably be a
similar color but like it's like a mousy
Brown yeah but see that's kind of what's
always I've always had like slightly
darker Roots but when it grows out it's
always like kind of a like a new Penny
kind of color is like an
orange are good with red hair yeah I
have been thinking about doing it again
but it is kind of pain in the ass then
you have to strip all the black out of
that yeah I'd have to bleach it yeah and
I think the last time I did it I had to
bleach it three times over a couple of
days and who knows what that would do to
that hair well I didn't have too much
damage last time I did
it but that was a while back yeah cuz
remember I was kind of experimenting
with different colors I bleached it I
dyed it purple for a little while I dyed
it bright red for a little while um what
other color did I
do I can't remember I think I did like a
lavender I didn't like that though so
like I tried some different stuff but I
don't know it's just I'm kind of a low
maintenance gal you know what I mean
earlier on somebody asked me if I had
seen the aliens in the shopping mall I I
hadn't seen
it I don't know if somebody came up with
any
images I saw I was scrolling through
Facebook earlier and I saw that Steve
Mara was on there like maybe talking
about that okay yeah but I didn't watch
it if you guys don't know who that is J
Jen did a book with a Steve books with
that I did two books I did two books
with him he's a good guy he's a British
parapsychologist who work yeah yeah he's
pretty good yeah that was a while back I
did a show about um the rdale
Poltergeist case and the um Demon House
one in Seattle Keith Linder case because
he investigated that too yeah so yeah we
wrote books about that yeah and Demon
House went sideways over
time yeah not real sure how I feel about
that keth started getting [__]
obsessed with that I think he started
making [__] up
that's just what I'm thinking after not
not during the when you wrote the book
after yeah I think after
after yeah I'm not really sure what
happened with that his story started to
get Wilder and Wilder and
Wilder and then he wrote a book too yeah
I haven't read it but yeah he wrote a
book too like a year or two after I did
and Steve did find some stuff audio data
yeah it was weird [__] weird [__] that
happened in that house he thought
something weird was happening there cuz
I
came at it from the point of view I said
I'm just gonna write this book because I
wrote it with him so I was like I'm just
gonna I'm not gonna make any comment
about I'm gonna bring up obviously what
Keith Linder had said prior to Steve
getting there but it's mostly from
Steve's point of view it's all from
Steve's notes it's all from like the
time that he was he was there for like
three weeks or something like that and
like all the stuff that he found you
know what I mean I had like some
background information and stuff but it
was mostly him so I I'm I have no idea
like what happened after that or what he
claimed happened after that that's all
I'm saying I'm just going by what Steve
said when he was there and some weird
[__] happened I did the interviews with
Steve and got all the damn audio data
that she used to compile the book out
of and so I didn't have to read the book
I heard the raw data yeah and um having
been through Mammoth Mountain what
happened to me and [__] that still
happens and here every now and then I
think there was something to it but I
also think that Linder wanted to kind of
get famous off of
it it wasn't enough so it's like he
started to add to it
but we Jen and Steve really did kind of
separate out what Linder was saying he
saw and then what Steve actually saw
during his investigation and what Steve
saw in his investigation he thought
there was something going on on there
there wasir yeah and he had he had um
actual audio data and [__] audio
anomalies like things falling off of
[__] what was it it was a smoke
detector or something or no it was a it
was a light a light you know those
lights that you like just kind of stick
on the walls yeah that's that's what it
was an Adhesive Light it fell off the
wall he got it on videotape it fell off
the wall and when it
hit it gave a [__] weird audio
signature to the microphone it was
really really loud yeah it was like it
was really loud and he wasn't able to
recreate it he dropped it from the same
height and it wouldn't make that quite
same
signature it's almost kind of like it
which is we me and Jen have seen
that yeah like when it threw the remote
control when it thr the remote control
when it hit the ground it sound like a
damn brick hit it did like whack and we
couldn't recreate that [__]
sound so that's why I thought that was
really interesting yeah because I was
like that was what happened at our
house I think it might have been some
kind of mild Poltergeist
disturbance but he thought it was
demonic so it got worse and then I think
he I particularly later on after Jen
wrote the book some of the [__] that he
came up with I think he
faked try to get possibly yeah wasn't
there but cuz the thing about it was
that well even in the early stages yeah
um when Steve Mara went there with his
uh people cuz he had two other D like
people with him when he went there to
Seattle and stayed in the house cuz he
stayed in the house I think he the first
time he stayed for two weeks I think and
then like he came back like later and
stayed for another week or something so
it was a while and they lived there they
lived in the house and set up all their
[__] now I will note that the stuff that
Keith Linder had reported before Steve
got there was much
crazier than what Steve ended up seeing
but Steve did end up seeing some [__] in
there that was pretty [__] weird and
I was actually more interested in that
because look you can say anything you
know what I mean you can say like oh my
God all this crazy [__] like happened in
my house and like all this writing
appeared on the walls or whatever but
it's like if there's nobody there to
corroborate that or there's no
scientific backing for that then that's
just your word you know what I mean you
could just make it up or you could have
just imagined it or whatever so I just
kind of concentrated mostly on Steve
getting there and it's like I put in the
book like you know Keith prior to Steve
getting there like you know Keith said
he saw this that and the other thing
like I kind of went down on it but then
um you know when Steve got there I went
very much into the scientific
investigation day by day like what they
saw every single day and he saw some
weird [__] it wasn't as crazy as what he
had reported previously but it was still
pretty weird we worked with Steve in two
books and I found Steve to be um very
controlled and
organized open-minded to
stuff and honest he's not the kind of
person that would make something up yeah
what he does is he'll give both sides
this could have happened they're saying
this he's just kind of presenting
everything he's like an old school
parapsychologist yeah and then he'll go
in there and goes well okay this is what
they're saying this is what I'm this is
what I found when I went there and then
he's kind of like you be the judge and
then he's like what could this be yeah
right like he always tries to like yeah
go through well it could be this it
could be you know it could be any number
of other like rational things before he
jumps in I went out looking for
parapsychologists to work with because
you know me and Jen wanted to write
books Jen wanted to write a book and he
was the one that I selected and he
worked with
us yeah yeah Zach says is he someone I
could get in touch with I'd love to ask
him some questions about telekinesis
yeah for the script he's wearing yeah
yeah yeah actually if you um I could
probably put you into yeah yeah yeah I
mean he's still around he still does you
know what's crazy we were
watching uh that unexplained show with
William Shatner we were watching an
episode the other day from like the
latest season I don't remember what
season it was and Steve was on there and
I was like hey it's Steve yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't remember what show it was
but yeah I was just like holy [__] that
looks like Steve because I had seen him
in a while but yeah that was him he
looks the same doesn't he pretty much
pretty much yeah I was just like
surprised cuz I wasn't expecting to see
him so it's like I saw on that
unexplained show I can't what show was
it what was the topic I can't remember
what the topic was that that was the one
with Shatner right yeah yeah yeah I
don't remember what topic was I don't
remember either but it's just I was just
kind of like funny because I wasn't
expecting to see Steve on there and I
was like oh there he is I don't remember
if it was a ghost show or an aliens show
ghost because he talks about aliens also
but yeah well he'll talk about anything
yeah anything par like I said he's not
Steve smart he doesn't get real
committal he's very non-committal he
just presents well that's a very scien
View and he's kind of like a lawyer and
then he'll go in there and he'll tell
you what he
found and he does sometimes find stuff
sometimes he doesn't find things but um
in the Linder case he did find some
stuff yeah there was some weird [__]
that happened in that house okay and he
couldn't quite explain
right like I said not as splashy as what
Keith was reporting right but it was we
so I don't think he was just like making
it up out of Po of cloth but maybe he
was he might have been exaggerating or
there's a possibility too and I think I
put this in the book that you know maybe
it just had died down by the time that
he got there I don't know yeah cuz some
of the stuff he was saying was like kind
of out there you know I'm not saying it
didn't happen I'm just saying they
didn't well Bible's catching on fire and
things being written and weird [__] like
that but it was just on his word and
that's what I mean there was he did
produce burned up Bibles but I you know
I can but anybody can burn a Bible and
say yeah I found it right so you don't
know I'm not saying he did that I'm just
saying you could do that you could yeah
so you're going to need a little more
proof than that right but that's okay I
got to pee okay you talk she wants me to
talk now what you don't you never have a
problem talking she walk away from me
that
booty don't walk away she turns around
go what booty the booty that booty
that's following behind you
oh no yeah wherever she goes there's a
booty fler
behind all
right see what's going on here see she's
telling me to talk I I talk when I'm
ready to talk I just don't uh I'm not
like a a dancing monkey you know what
I'm talking about especially not in
front of y'all
let's see what everybody's talking about
here yeah that was n asking about the
aliens in the mall that was here in
Florida um a mall called the cops and
were saying that there was youths going
crazy in the mall and there was a huge
massive police response to
it they were evidently shooting off fire
fireworks and
stuff but then other people said no it
wasn't that that it wasn't kids that
there were aliens running around in the
mall I think they 10 foot tall 10 foot
tall aliens running in the mall oh come
on that's what they said yeah yeah and I
don't know what they were talking about
maybe I don't I haven't seen any video
footage cuz somebody just made that [__]
up yeah I kind of heard like
peripherally like that that was going on
I'm just like whatever
yeah I don't have time for that kind of
nonsense what Tammy say Tammy said you
would dance if I had motorcycle money
yeah she said yeah I dance without the
motorcycle money well no she's talking
about um the pegging thing oh is that
that cuz she was talking about that
earlier [__] you girls cuz I said hey
you're the one that said that you would
do it for a certain amount of money and
I told I
advised behind the scenes
I advised I was like it's probably
better to not tell anybody what that
amount is there's always a price you
know some's going to come up with it and
then you're going to have to put your
money where your mouth is or you're
going to have to put your money where
your ass is there's a price for
everything you know
so I would not war let me warn you dudes
about these women okay there's something
in them there's there's this there's
this [__] thing in them I don't
understand it I don't know if it has
something to do with uh Power d Dynamics
or whatever they're trying to hit a man
in the
ass that's like the greatest fantasy is
to strap some across the board I don't
know if I wouldn't I don't know if I'd
say that was my you're not the only one
no I know you're not the only one don't
know if top tier fantasy but it is kind
of like had a lot of them over the years
ask me for some [__] like that I'm like
no I'm
good yeah I mean I guess you can say
because you're pretty seasoned you've
been around yeah
so out of your I I don't know what your
body count is exactly you probably don't
know either it's no triple digits it's
yeah it's below triple digits it's high
but um so you've had a sampling yeah of
of a large not I mean you know but you
got to understand say when I count I
don't count the way women count women
won't count dudes that they didn't like
they won't count dud they won't count
dudes that there wasn't any damn [__]
vag penetration they'll say oh that was
just anal that's not sex or no that was
just head that wasn't sex yeah see I
count that when I blew those four Dudes
that didn't count you know what I mean
count they won't count I count
everything if I come then I count it I
would count all of that I count
everything if I so if I if I if I catch
a nut I count it and I'm probably
because it wasn't all of it [__] is
[__] conventional sex I didn't even
lose my virginity [__] conventional
sex really [__] I lost that [__]
through the back I
[__] yeah yeah my first time was
[__] I went a on a
chick she didn't want to get pregnant
all right it's called the loophole yeah
the loophole that's what they call it
yeah so and in a way I didn't count that
until later I was like no that [__]
counted well yeah yeah that [__] counted
I pretty I would count I was young I was
young yeah I mean I would count anything
I mean if it's just like making out or
something like that that doesn't count
but well I mean but that depends but
it's just kind of like like you
said yeah I most all of that counts that
all counts
but it's got to be triple digits because
I I'll forget so that's what I was
thinking but I don't look at it that way
it was just I was it's just in the
moment well and the thing about it is
that I was lucky I had happened to be a
a good-look guy when I was young and
going to South America from with a
wealthy family and I had a car at
[__] 17 in Brazil that was a [__]
big deal okay [__] um and just uh
being in the drama program of my boy
isn't here is he gr's he was here he was
here earlier we were in a drama we were
in a drama program together if in
Michigan because I did part of the time
in Michigan part of the time in Brazil I
went to high school and both and I went
like an extra year because I was losing
credits every time I go back to the
United States and um
I was
popular and uh it was easy it was easy
until I hit about
20 that is big dry spell you can't
compete against guys in their 30s
they're sucking up all women they got
the money so then they go into the army
yeah and then hookers well I went to
Korea yeah and that was wild all right
but like most of the time I was working
this was not a [__] hooker Fest you
know what I mean well you said you only
got leave like once a month or something
once a month I got 12 you only like once
a month you go house I got pass I got
pass about once a month and I'd go down
to Tom Desa or a [__] eay W also
known as hooker Hill
yeah and uh have fun you know what I
mean
um and you have a [__] wallet full of
cash you know lot of money don't have
spending it you got no way to spend it
so you go to [__] hooker Hill with
$1,000 in your [__]
pocket and those girls are only asking
for like
30 yeah not that's a bargain just a
bargain it's a bargain and [__] uh
the the the liquor is cheap and you had
a good time and they were nice girls I
don't I didn't look down on them I don't
know how they got into that business but
they were young and like I said I it was
they were doing their Duty which is try
to get every bit of money out of your
pocket and put that [__] it's a job just
like anything else it's like I said I
don't I don't begrudge anybody doing
that and it wasn't personal and it was
just um you know they were providing
were yeah they were trying to just
basically
Shield Korean civilian women from us
sure to keep all keep keep us [__]
busy like I said it sounds like a lot
because Zach says so basically Thomas
the Town
Bicycle every Everybody rides him well
no we'll see I high standards well and
the thing about it too is that you were
single for most of your life yeah um he
was married but you were married for
what two years yeah like your first
marriage was 10 was two years yeah and
then so you were single your entire yeah
teenag most of your 20s and I was in
male dominated societies military
schools armies and [__] worked for
companies that were doing security
Contracting so I wasn't around women all
the
time and if I was around women they were
a lot of times professional women in
certain SP spots yeah and they're
there's the oldest profession in the
world is to is to be a hooker okay the
second oldest profession is to be a
soldier it's the same thing yeah all
right um they're both selling your
bodies to Old Men it's just one's
[__] and other one's fighting yeah
you're keeping the old man laid the
girls are keeping the old man laid the
boys are keeping the old man in on his
sex Island somewhere in Rich that's what
you're doing and um you're both
disposable but I always kind of had a
soft spot for the professional women
because the dudes were given honor at
least they give you uniforms and little
bits of [__] colored ribbon to all
your special [__] that you did the women
were treated like [__] basically sh the
women were treated like [__] they still
are I mean it's better it is a lot
better yeah now than it used to be but
they're still kind of Trigg like right
right and they were taken just as much
risks as we were yeah cuz they could get
killed doing what they're doing oh Big
Time a lot of them do yeah I write about
it all the time and then when you come
out of those businesses you're [__] up
all right you're just not [__] up in
the same way that girl will have a hard
time getting back into society in
relationships and the guy will have a
hard time getting back into Rel Sim but
it's very different reasons like I had a
problem getting back into it because I
wanted to [__] people up you know and I
didn't want to play by society's rules
you know like me mean I can't kill that
dude the [__] you talking about that
[__] is bad I'm going to cut his
head off what are you talking about
although I kind of feel like that yeah
you know and they like they don't
understand me PR minor sh these
[__] don't understand me you
know what I mean it's just just like
that and a lot a lot of people in the
comments sections that know me you know
[__] like murder Hornet and [__] he's
he's a vet he's a VA guy I you know I
got VA disability for PTSD and multiple
head injuries and all kinds of
[__] it's just it's rough on you
and the female version of me is it's
rough on her she's probably toothless
now [__] a crackhead you know [__]
can't they get it worse the girls
actually get it worse and it's been
going on for [__] thousands of years
yeah and like I said you can't really
like I said it's better now than it was
but you can't really ever shed that
stigma yeah either like once you've been
a sex worker that's a WRA um even now
people are still going to be like yeah
like later on like you're not going to
be material you're not going to be wife
material it's better than it was like
people are more understanding about it
nowadays but it's still not yeah you're
you're not going to be wife material and
cu the only guys that are looking for
wives really are guys in their 20s and
30s and they're looking for Virgin
Territory basically look somebody that
could be the mother of their children
and [__] that's not going to be a some
ex-hooker yeah they don't want to think
about their kids being no mothered by
someone that used to be a sex work even
though they're a nice person they just
don't want anything to do with that
that's just too much problem yeah it's
what well it's kind of weird because I
kind of feel like dudes are all into sex
workers when they want that you know
what I mean they want marry them but
they don't want to marry them or
anything like that hell it's a whole
different thing which you know she's a
mercenary
woman she's going and like I said a lot
of times she was kind of I a lot of
people don't choose that to be honest
it's just kind of like circumstances
they come
ccum no [__] money no family support
but same there a lot that's where a lot
of soldiers come from yeah same thing so
yeah like you said it's kind of the same
thing you know what I mean they they
have to leave home they don't have any
other can't stay there they're young
they got a lot of energy they're [__]
you know you you can be a man of action
so you sell yourself into an
army yeah now some countries don't even
have that but I happen to be lucky to be
living in the United States and you
could sell yourself to the Empire which
is what I did you know if you did that
in Russia in the Soviet Union well first
of all they drafted you you had to go
you didn't really get anything out of it
yeah so you know let me go rest oh
Joseph says the um The Unexplained
episode was the search for
extraterrestrial life the one that had
Steve Mar okay all right he knows that
one that's right I thought that it was
maybe a UFO one because I feel like he's
pivoted more to like talking about UFOs
lately I'm not entirely sure but like I
said we you know when I wrote books with
him and stuff we were talking about
polter guys [__] mostly like hauntings
and stuff because that's kind of what he
was doing at that point but I think he's
pivoted a little bit to like doing more
UFO stuff he does
um a uh they do like a monthly magazine
that comes out too and they write about
UFO stuff and paranormal stuff but I
feel like UFO is mostly that's what
everybody wants to read about I and you
know what it's like I always find ghost
[__] more interesting than UFO
[__] yeah I know like UFOs could be real
and everything like that but I don't
know for for some reason I just don't
find that all that interesting I think
ghosts are way more
interesting um yeah wait I saw something
that I wanted to answer but maybe it
just went
away oh I think it was Danny that said
something and it's like CU his his
comments like disappear after a few
minutes I'm not really sure why that is
that must be some setting that he has on
but he said something and I was going to
comment on it and now I can't remember
what it was it's just popped up at the
bottom
but I don't know I do
like I do I I like that I like that
you see sex workers the same way that
you see soldiers cuz like you said when
you point it out like when you point out
like that it is pretty much the same
thing like it's different it's different
experiences obviously but it's it's a
different job but it's it's it's
essentially they're gendered thing the
male gendered of that job basically the
equipment would be
Soldier [__] working in a brow or a
hooker it's a [__] like that that's the
female equivalent because the female's
best job in something like that would be
an
Entertainer that goes way back [__]
to to be honest it's like I'm kind of
like I don't um look down on women that
do that because it's like I wouldn't
want to do that like I said you got be
tough well I mean yeah I mean we do
videos and [__] like that but it's like
that's easy we we just do this me and
you just in our house and [__] like that
other people are watching but it's like
not that big ofal the problem with the
females their problems are are different
because with a female the act of sexual
copulation is a lot more personal than
it is for a guy for guy it's not very
personal it's not very it's not invasive
really and we're just built to do that
you know what I mean [__] sperm is
cheap eggs are not cheap not at all so a
woman feels like she's being kind of
invaded
yeah well she has to kind of numb
herself to that and allow the
client to have his way without getting
feels for the dude or to [__] hate
herself yeah so it has to be kind of
hard to do which has to be kind of like
a mechanical act and or and it has to be
kind of like what do you call it acting
yeah something it's it's a
presentation or you know you're
entertaining this client and and then
you have to be able to step away from it
well that can [__] a lot of women up
because they're just not built for it I
don't think the average woman's built
for it they're always going to be kind
of [__] feel like they're slightly
violated by it some women can take to it
but it's not normal like I said um you
know I have known some women or heard of
some women that were into it and really
liked that and it really didn't seem to
bother them but that's a that's a
minority yeah most women even if they do
it for a long time um they have
mechanisms because it's not a normal
situation so you really have to like I
would never be able to do anything like
that well because one um I'm not good at
pretending to like some dude to like
people right I'm really bad at that um
you know some people are good at that
but I am not it probably be a good
dominatrix though I yeah and we actually
discussed this because I was like I
could I could do that like I could have
a dude come in and I could just like
spit on him and step on his nuts and
[__] like I could do that and like tell
him how much he sucked I'm like yeah I
could do that because that would be real
yeah you know what I mean because I'd be
like yeah you're disgusting and like I
said like that would actually be fun
kind of but it's just like if I have to
like pretend to like you and it's like o
look at this penis you're giving this
dude a girl I can't do that you giving
this dude a girlfriend experience you
don't like him or if you do like him you
give him the girlfriend experience and
all of a sudden you're in love with him
but then he just paid and he's got a
he's got a woman right he's got a wife
back at home so now you're [__] up so
the I think the average woman doesn't do
well I would not recommend that that I
don't recommend that profession there's
only a certain kind of woman that can do
it and I've done the [__] profiling
of the ones that can do
it the ones that can do it tend to be
older over 30 maybe they already have
kids they've already been married and
they've already done that they've
already done the traditional [__] so now
they're going to go James Bond and
they're going to become a mercenary sure
I get it they might do that for a while
and um but you see that's a lot more of
a healthy situation because that woman
knows who she is and who she isn't so
she can role play better yeah she
doesn't take it personally because she
this isn't me I'm just doing this yeah
I'm just going into a different like and
if the dude says something sideways to
her like [__] you don't know me yeah
she can just Shug it off right because
she's acting it's a lot harder when
you're young when you're young when you
haven't really established haven't
really establish your identity to that's
why dudes like Epstein in the show are
talk he was looking for girls that were
molested at a really early age because
they have identity
problems you get in on honestly I don't
think I really got my [__] together I
mean and and I'm kind of a person I'm
kind of unusual because I kind of feel
like I knew what I was like early yeah
but even then
I still wasn't sure what was going on
until probably my mid to late 30s yeah
you know what I mean because you still
hold kind of ideas that aren't supported
by truth that sure and it's just so a
while to realize that yeah this is not
the way this the way they told me it is
is not really the way it is and the
thing about it's like even now like you
know now that I'm you know in my early
50s and it's just kind of like um you
know even now I still have like a lot of
holdover [__] from back then which you
know you try to get rid of but it never
really leaves you but I do think it's
gotten a lot better than cuz [__] man
like I was married to my first husband
till I was what 38 or something like
that and then after that I kind of just
went [__] wild because I hadn't
really done that much in my teenage
years so I was just kind of like woo I'm
free and blah blah and I did all this
other kind of crazy [__] that I probably
wouldn't have done otherwise but that's
why I gave you your dis inspected yeah I
know all right [__] and that was that
was that was
Sonia she was like she was like you
don't want to hook up with her right now
she's brand new she was kind of right
about that she let her live I was
banging everybody yeah well no I not
everybody maybe like three people was
Jen's body count is barely into [__]
double digits it's not even I think it's
maybe eight I think is what my body
which to me is amazing really well I was
married for a long time I was married
for 14 years and I never on that dude I
don't do that so um you know that's just
not my thing yeah
so um so yeah most of most of my body
count was racked up after I got divorced
yeah I watched it happen yeah you did
you were there for a lot of it you were
good though you picked good dudes yeah
I'm not nice I'm not totally stupid no
no they were nice guys no one hit me
nobody did nothing like that yeah so
people like what the [__] you talking
about me and Jim were friends before we
were going out we H we hung out the club
together for a long time we hooked up a
couple times but we
weren't official yeah it was just we
were dating other people it was a weird
thing where it's just kind of like I was
um we became best friends and then it
started to yeah like was it like I was
getting divorced yeah when we met yeah I
think we kind of hooked up a couple
times when you were getting divorced
when I was in the middle of the divorce
yeah and then you were separated though
he knew oh yeah yeah he knew he knew
yeah we weren't sleeping in the same
room or anything we were living in the
same house we were sleeping in the same
room like he knew what was going on and
um cuz we had already decided at that
point we were just working out how [__]
was going to go with the house and
everything so um so we but then like you
were kind of dating other people I was
dating other people but we just kind of
started we were just we just hung out
all time we could stop hanging out with
each other just constantly [__] yeah
it's just even when we were dating other
people we just like like ah well I'll
drive you to the club we would hang out
the club talk about people we were
dating yeah like that [__] is this and
that or like yeah this you know just we
talk [__] about the people we were
dating with sometimes depending on what
the situation was maybe at the same time
and then like after a while of doing
that everybody we knew were just like
why don't Jesus Christ why don't you
guys just go out yeah for [__] sake
they were just like tired of seeing us
together years yeah like a year and year
and a half something like that but you
know finally yeah okay um
Joseph says can you believe in ghosts
and still be an atheist yeah you can
because an atheist a person doesn't
believe in a
religion and uh you don't have to
believe in a religion to see a ghost I
consider myself basically a mythicist or
that's kind of atheist I am absolutely
an atheist but I've been in bad houses
that I wouldn't call it a ghost but
maybe like a ghost but I couldn't see
anything and then I've also seen
Poltergeist which is not a ghost but I
don't know if I actually believe in
ghosts as in depend on how you the
lingering Spirit of someone that once
lived yeah um I'm not sure if that could
happen more like a psychic impression in
the area yeah I kind of feel like
because the thing about it is that if
there's ghost phenomena or paranormal
phenomena of some kind like Poltergeist
stuff I think there's a scientific
explanation for it we just don't know
what it is yet I think is what it is so
I don't think that it's necessarily I
don't think you necessarily have to
believe in a higher power or anything
like that because I think they're two
different things because I absolutely do
not and I've been an Atheist for since I
was a kid like
so but I'm pretty skeptical about
paranormal [__] too I'm very skeptical
about it but you know what I've seen it
but I don't think that
it's ghost or demons or anything like
that I thought that that's you doing
that yeah you know what I mean weird
[__] was happening as my dad was dying I
didn't know he was dying some or not
consciously our smoke alarms kept going
off kept going off that was one thing
that kept happening before we found out
that your dad was dying yeah it was
trying to tell me something yeah our
smoke alarms kept going on yeah like the
one in the bedroom would go off yeah
like it it would beep like several times
and then the one in the hall would beep
couple a bunch of times and then it
would stop yeah which and we just
changed the battery in the bedroom one
cuz it was making that noise like a
month ago and it started going I was
watching Frighteners and [__]
Lieutenant damers was [__] going on
about his his your psychic phenomenon is
[__] making this Jeffrey comes and I
was [__] love zooming into what he
was saying I was getting freaked out
and and I walked underneath there and it
did a couple more of them and then it
stopped isn't it funny at this like at
this
stage when like I always know when
you're upset about something yeah
because some weird [__] will happen that
like the TV will turn itself on and off
or the smoke alarm will go off or yeah
something will fly off
the the bookshelf or something like and
I'm like oh Tomas be upset about
something because you don't say usually
but that's but that's kind of what I
think so that's why I'm not scared of it
usually although if you got mad enough
like I said you might like Wing a brick
at my head or
something I don't know that wouldn't
hurt you I don't think I don't think you
would yeah cuz you never seem to get
that mad at me it's not me it's
another it's another version of me it's
another facet of me it's a thing that
controls [__] characters in your
dreams at night the other characters I
don't trust it fully you know but you
know well I don't think you know it
doesn't it doesn't have anything against
you if anything think it would hurt me
yeah but you know I'm always going to
worry it's just kind of like you know
when you were on Trend yeah and you know
you were saying all this crazy [__] and
I was like afraid that you were going to
like murder me cuz that has happened I
have not murdered you what are you but
when did I murder you
no yeah you murdered me before you said
that happened no no I said I was worried
that you would murder me that's what I
said so um so then like you told me
later it's like oh I never would have
hurt you I was just like worried about
like dudes and stuff but see didn't know
that so like at the time I was like oh
my God he's just going to shoot me in
the back of the head one night cuz he's
acting all crazy and [__] like that no I
had no I had no anger towards you at all
I know but see I didn't I didn't know
that cuz you were acting crazy yeah well
you were well you were acting like
erratic so I didn't really know what to
I didn't notice it well of course you
didn't notice it but I noticed it so
that's why I was saying it's like I know
in real life you know you know given
that you're normal you would never hurt
me ever yeah I know that but it's just
kind of like I wasn't sure because you
were acting like a lunatic so I was just
kind of like um this is bad it's like
it's I was just thinking like you get
upset and you'd like shoot me in the
back of the head one night when I was
sleeping or something like I didn't know
like I didn't know no I wasn't mad at
you at all I know but it seemed like you
were no I wasn't though it seemed like
you yeah yeah you told me that later
yeah but I you didn't ask me you should
have asked me had you asked
I was scared to really to be honest no
Trend [__] makes you go crazy but I
wasn't mad at you I was I was scared to
ask you anything no because of the crazy
[__] you were saying yeah I was just
kind of like if I ask him about it he's
just going to be like he's going to go
off on me and I don't know what's going
to
happen there I mostly kept myself I was
trying to hide yeah and I didn't know
what was going on with that either
because like I said you didn't you
didn't tell me until later so it was
just kind of like I [__] I knew Trad
had me Tad makes you makes you a [__]
werewolf it makes you the goblin out of
[__] Spider-Man right so it's like so
that's kind of the same thing like with
the polter I thing yeah it's like I know
in real life 99.9% of the time you would
never ever hurt me in real life I know
you wouldn't but it's just kind of like
what if you got like super mad at me
when for whatever reason like I don't
ever do anything that would make you
that mad I wouldn't think but if I I
don't really get mad you don't well I
mean you know I don't know no uh I don't
get mad last time you got really really
mad at me I don't even remember that I
don't think I get mad at you I don't
even remember you getting like super mad
at
me I don't do anything that maddening I
feel like you know what I mean not like
that dude you were talking about on the
police video you watched earlier oh
yeah there's a uh yeah he was telling me
about this channel called police
activity it's on YouTube he loves that
[__] I can hear I can hear the yelling
from down the yeah I'll be [__] don't
do
it dudes will [__] straight from
Venezuela will be sitting there and see
the cops and the cops want to talk to
him and he just like bows up and pulls a
knife and runs straight at the cops like
you can do that over because you you
know I grew up partially in South
America I kind of know what they're
thinking cops in South and Central
America are just they're they're they
write tickets they don't they can't
shoot anybody they'll get in trouble so
they come here so much paperwork yeah
they they they come here and cops want
to talk to him and they'll just [__]
try to intimidate the cops and chase
them off by pulling a knife these are
New York cops man they [__] cut him
down in a hail of
gunfire [__] they just kill you and
they did it in front of one of the other
dudes and they were just like oh yeah if
you run at the cop with a [__] knife
you shoots you he kills you you move too
[__] quickly in front of a [__]
cop he'll actually you just reach for
your pocket and they'll probably shoot
you yeah if he's got a gun out on you
you stay right there and you [__]
reach for your pocket you're dead man
all right this is the [__] Wild West
it it was never not the wild west there
was the wild west and it got
Wilder as the United States aged all
right don't [__] make a [__] quick
move around these cops they'll just cut
you low all right I and there will be no
questions asked because they're just
following the orders and they got
cameras on them and they'll go yeah
that's right he made a quick move and
[__] grabbed into his pocket yeah
there you go all right they'll get away
with it well I would do it too if I said
you right you dude reached into his
pocket no I'm going to kill you cuz you
might be pulling out a gun total
obedience or I kill you you know that I
come from that
culture uh that's the way it was in the
military that's the way it be in
police I show up I'm in charge any
[__] problem like I'll just kill you
you know because I want to go home at
night I want to get my
pay I don't care if it hurts your
feelings or your families cry I hope
they cry real [__] hard you know what
I mean it's just Darwin happening
anyway dude you makeing me talk about
this shooting now well you were talking
about it earlier so I thought you might
want to got some scissors he's trying to
kill himself he's threatening to kill
himself the cops show up well the reason
why he wanted to kill himself is that's
that's why I brought it up yeah he had
his little his little wife was uh
cheated on him he went through her phone
found out she was cheating on him with
some black dude she was going to school
with and he's [__] losing so he got
um a little upset yeah he told the cops
he's asked him oftion I feel he says you
got he was done he was through he goes I
did everything for you and this blah
blah blah blah he's going off on this
little girl she's crying oh Max be oh
Max it's going to be okay [__] and um
the cops like man man we don't want to
[__] do it just settle down bro we
know you're upset and he's like [__] it
I'm sick of this [__] he goes if he
asked if you guys ever killed anybody
before ask me if you ever shot anybody
before they're not answering the
question and [__] he just runs
straight at him with some scissors and
they just [__] mow him down right in
front of the wife I mean did that on
purpose well he said he wanted to die
well the thing about it well like I said
the reason I brought that up was because
you mentioned it before and I was just
kind of
like I can't imagine oh well you know no
I can't imagine I can't imagine being
that mad at your spouse or your
girlfriend or whatever it a spouse they
were married that you would just let the
cops shoot you he was he was through he
said he wanted to go I can't I can't
imagine being that upset about it this
dude was upet I'm not saying that it but
not so upset that I'd let cops shoot me
well the comment section is like why' he
kill himself over that
hoe had he just calmed down [__] the
next day he he he would have just left
her well see that's kind of what yeah it
well and the thing about it and that
happens a lot it's like people do [__]
In the Heat of the Moment it's like yeah
you know I get it I get that he was
really upset I'd have been really upset
if the same thing it happened to me but
you have to think that well
well you run into a hail of
gunfire yeah you know you're not you
know tomorrow a couple days from
now everything might look a little bit
different it was funny cuz he was going
through I rate and then he get calm and
he talk to the cops like he goes he's
like look man I know you guys don't have
anything to do with this I don't really
you have forgive me for putting you
through this you know because he's I
mean at least he did that yeah yeah yeah
but then he [__] charged him with
that [__] pair of I mean the cops are
probably like well we didn't want to
have to shoot to do it either because
now we have all this paperwork to go
through and they got to go to like the
therapy and all that I got it all on
camera they
[__] but you know well I don't think
I mean they wouldn't have gotten trouble
I'm just saying that they usually have
to after they shoot a person they
usually like send them to therapy and
they do all this paperwork and [__] like
that they have to go through this old
rigal you know what I mean yeah um
American Military 100 says oh Jenny Tom
would never murder you that's your
immersion in the True Crime research
that cause you to think that yeah that's
what it is yeah but see you never know
because this is how these [__] are
you can't well you can't now a sudden
I'm a murderer no no no nobody said that
hold on let me go rest I'm just saying
that a lot of times you watch yeah I do
watch a lot of True Crime but it's like
um we're going to share
this well there would be good if there
was more ice in
it well you want it'll water it
down just drink it I'm from Florida I
want I want ice in my [__] you know what
I mean I don't like this BR t
temperature drink C that's not Roat
that's cold it's not cold oh [__] listen
to how these [__] [__] dve me down
okay all right well I mean you're going
that way I wasn't going that way you
were you're going to the bathroom you're
coming right by the ice machine oh my
goodness
so so yeah so anyway I remember what I
was talking about but yeah
so see that's kind of what I worry about
because you hear these cases where she's
like like you know I started going out
with this dude we got married we were
married for like years and years we had
kids and all this other kind of crap and
then all of a sudden this dude's doing
all kind of crazy [__] well look at okay
like cases we've talked about thank you
cases we've talked about online look at
like [__] BTK or something like that
[__] was married had kids years and
years she didn't know [__] about that
she didn't know [__] about that and so
that's always I do I trust him 100% well
9.99% as much as I trust anybody but
it's like you can't trust anybody 100%
because there's always that thought in
the back of my mind always that thought
man BTK did all that [__] for like 30
[__] years and his wife and his kids
didn't know you know it's like I always
think that I can't help it that's just
that's just the way I am that's just the
way I am like I said I'm in all that
true crime [__] I know it's rare
but it does happen I know he would he
seriously he would never ever ever do
anything
but there's always that I'm just you
know always that tiny tiny little
percentage tiny
percentage uh let's
see um okay so where oh Zach said um so
he's talking about the script this
character has
telekinesis and he's learning how to
control it because it keep keeps
involuntarily activating from stress oh
my God I love that idea that's awesome
he has empathic uh abilities too that
overwhelm and his on top of that Zach is
talking about yeah but yeah so that's
what I I said dude I do I do trust you I
know you wouldn't murder me probably but
it's just you know what I mean [__] I
watch so much True Crime [__] it's just
like so there's always that tiny little
thought in the back of my mind Sierra
Sierra women love to be scared is he a
seral killer women love to be scared
well no it's not so we don't love to be
scared that I that's
inaccurate we don't like to
be ambushed we don't like to be taken by
surprise so you always have to have that
thought in the back of your mind maybe
this could go sideways you have to have
that um that warning thing on like all
the time you have to because you never
know so it's not so much that we like
that it's just the survival me mechanism
that's that's what it is Zach gay Zack
should I have my hat hat on or off I'm
going to leave it up to you some people
are saying you might put the wig on
maybe you should put the wi wig [__] man
I mean oh he might do a wig I'm going to
do a wig oh everybody's going to be
excited you haven't done a wig in a long
time find a wig in there don't close one
of the cats in the closet cuz I'm
watching Bambi likes to run in the
closet she got trapped in there one day
and I didn't know sheit L I literally
opened the closet for like a second
second and she like ran in there I guess
and I didn't see her and later she was
like yelling for me to let her out oh
he's putting on his like dancing wig I
got my favorite wig that's your favorite
one yeah you probably should brush it I
going to I'm just going to tell
you oh man this is [__] up I told you
you can't just this wig is [__] up you
can't just put them on you got to like
brush them and style them and stuff this
[__] here man looks
like what what the [__] look at this
[__] come on come on the thing this it's
great look at this F did you do to my
hair J I didn't do anything to it [__]
did you do to my hair
bro would you like none of this [__]
Works would you like a brush yeah none
of this [__] Works Tam's like
yeah oh my God none of this [__] works
so fun I love the wigs it's so easy for
you to put a wig on cuz you're bald yeah
but you do have to brush them I mean you
can't just like put them on and have
them look good this thing's got a
[__] little Zach says he looks like
the homeless dude from malland Drive
yeah not quite that bad you're going to
pop out from behind a dumpster my [__]
used to look pretty with this wig on
this wig is [__] up now I used to be
able to do
D it's all right just you gota well now
that I now that I have the beard and the
mustache though I look [__] funny you
don't no you don't you look like you
could be in like A's the like a Gothic
metal band yeah in the bathroom where it
always is there's all kind of brushes in
there although the Big Brush yeah that's
pooky's brush Pooky I got Pooky I got a
[__] brush all right all right yeah
okay now I found a [__] pretty boy
brush I'm going get pretty with this
[__] that one's like not super stiff so
you might have a hard time but we'll see
how it goes yeah is that one okay I'm
going to start brushing my hair these
girls are going to love it oh my God
yeah is it like ASMR yeah I am your
king
I am your king oh there you go some you
like that oh yeah Zach says idea for
this year's Halloween costumes you
should dress as each other that would
never
work you don't you don't have good boobs
yeah you'd have to you'd have to get
your tits pierced yeah which I'll do
it but you won't let me do it uh just
like you won't let me Peg
you it's [__] women man
I'm just teasing you I'm just teasing
you so this is what would
happen GNA send out a warning to you
dudes all right don't ever let these
women don't ever let these women try to
Peg you because what'll happen is is
[__] they'll start off with something
small okay and [__] well yeah I'm not
going to stick like a big [__] they
start with something small and then all
of a sudden you're GNA go yeah that's
not that bad and then before you know it
she's got you like getting bigger and
bigger and then you're like having to
have sex with fire hydrants and [__]
you're jumped up and down on fire and
you're like a you're like a you're like
an ass King you know what I mean you're
like a ass like you're like a super
bottom see and then she's G to have you
all turned out and she's going to be
like I knew you were an asshle and she's
gonna [__] with you man do not [__]
do that [__]
man started on that road that [__] don't
start down that [__] road thing
though this you're
thing then she's going to tell all your
friends look at all
I would never she well
maybe see because it's about power
dynamics and they want to [__] they
want to tell everybody Tom you send porn
of me to people that I don't even know
about so no you know they're all people
you know I'm just saying you send it
without asking me so it's just to public
so why are you getting upset why do you
get upset you know no I'm just saying up
you shouldn't be upset if I told other
people about I'm in the porn a lot of
times too because thank you Jeffy art
for being such a sport Tom yeah I like
the hair just understand I'm just saying
you bought understand this probably I
mean I was going to say it's TMI but
holy [__] this is the Sidetrack show you
guys know how it goes you have bought me
some giant [__] dildos yeah but
they're mostly just for many of them are
painful they're just for looks though um
and I'll
you know I'm down with that it's just
for the [__] videos but you don't
want to do it though hell no you don't
want to do it it's not a man's
job all right see they try to put
something up in your booty man do not
[__] listen to these
women that's not a cool Tom so you want
me oh so take it up my ass makes it cool
no I'm just say no I said it wasn't cool
that you said Don't listen to
us we already have enough of a problem
with dud listening to us so it's you
know what I mean no I can I can go on
and on about how dudes actually
shouldn't listen to
women I can give I can give I can give
[__] examples well you you for sure
never listen to me I give examples there
are certain things why do you think
we're so frustrated with y'all all the
time don't don't don't do it no I'm just
saying y'all never listen because you
don't
listen real man doesn't
listen that's another shirt we should
make real man Donald Isen yeah well see
yeah we don't love that what
happened if you ask a woman all right
this has been proved you ask a woman
what she wants in a man she's going to
say well he's got to be a billionaire
he's got to be [__] every everybody
wants that he's got to [__] um have a
[__] sixpack and he's got to [__]
and she's going to name all this [__]
she'll never get you know what I mean
and she well that I will not settle for
anything l less than that then she goes
to the club meets a guy who's 5 foot
five she likes she goes out with him
don't listen to them they go I've told
you
before that's a stupid way of judging
what people's like types are that was
just because dudes say that [__] too
that's just basic though that's just a
Bas very basic thing very basic look at
who people end up with like in
relationships with yeah not who they who
their ideal thing is because like look
my ideal
house would be like a [__] castle in
Ireland with like that looked like
[__] Dracula [__] I know I'm never
going to have that yeah so it's like
that's dumb to think that it's like oh
all girls want to live in a [__]
castle that's stupid you know what I
mean like people's ideals that's not
boots on the ground that's not like
realistic yeah you know what I mean so
that's like what I'm saying that's just
an example that's like a dumb thing to
use as like a judge that's just an
example to like say that why you should
never listen to like what women say
because dudes say stupid [__]
too
um here's the like like you know well
also 300 lb 40-year-old dudes that are
like I want a hot 18yearold yeah they
got those that's like that's unrealistic
also but I understand I
understand um I understand why that is
ridiculous that's [__] ridiculous all
right I hear dudes say that I like you
Tripp that's what I mean it's ridiculous
always but like I said that's that's an
ideal and I think most people know that
that's not going to happen but uh then
there's other things that it's mostly
younger women saying this that I'm
seeing that they do this [__] on Tik
Tock although they don't say it much
anymore but they used to say well we
want guys that are emotionally available
and that they're well yeah everybody
wants like you know that they're
sensitive and [__] but then they [__]
meet guys like that and they friendzone
them that's not what they want they
actually like a dude who's [__]
pretty Alpha he's got a [__] six-pack
[__] all the other girls like him it
depends ignoring her she [__] likes
that dep if you give a woman too much of
attention especially early on before you
know her she's going to go oh he's
creepy you know so don't well if you're
too don't give me well it's a fine line
and like I said it's you can't say
across the board because everyone's
different so it's just kind of
like if a dude gives you too much
attention at like when you don't know
him that well yeah that comes across as
needy and so creepy that comes across as
creepy my advice dudes to you dudes is
basically ignore women the more you
ignore them the more they'll actually
like you if you look good because they
just see you as a
Loof now if you don't look good if you
don't look good it won't matter then it
won't matter invisible they'll ignore
you either way yeah 80% 80% of the dudes
are invisible and you have to be
realistic you have to know when you're
invisible and and it's going to be
pretty obvious now here's the thing
you've chosen to be invisible if you're
invisible because
basically [__] you get in the gym you
[__] get jacked and [__] you look
[__] great you're no longer invisible
and I've been looking at the [__]
data I looking at the
data having a good body and being jacked
actually a woman will take that over
height used to be that I thought that
[__] um the data would suggest that
if the dude's over six foot he's got it
made no cuz a lot of those dudes that
are over six foot are overweight or they
look like [__] or they don't have the
[__] they don't have any personality
it's not
important I could beat out of dudes in
there six feet six foot tall dudes all
the [__] time you know um just
because of other qualities women are
kind of in the general thing they like
an overall quality the overall score um
yeah well like I said I think we're a
lot
more I don't want to say forgiving but
we're a lot more flexible flexible yeah
um there's a lot more if you don't look
good quote unquote like if you're weird
looking or something like that that's
not a deal breaker like if you have a
bunch of other [__] that you could offer
like if you're super funny or you're
super interesting or yeah if you have
money charismatic or fun or something
like that then your looks don't really
matter as much I mean there are dudes
out there that are conventionally not
good-look but they're [__] babe
magnets you know uh uh some of them are
like Hollywood guys you know what I mean
who where you look at the dude and he's
kind of goofy looking but no women like
the dude like that dude from [__] we
were just talking about Bushi buim is
not Steve Bushi is is weirdly hot yeah
he's not he's not traditionally
good-looking but women like him he's
weirdly hot if you see certain
photographs of him in different roles
and [__] you can see why you know he he
and he's got a good character it's hard
for me to say because I mean this is
coming from a girl that my first crush
was um Ted Cassidy who played Lurch on
the original Adams Family Show so it's
just kind a striking appearance helps
guys that's what I mean I kind of like
striking I I don't necessarily like if
you're just like goodlook like I said a
lot of the um sort of like A-list type
of actors or whatever they all kind of
look the same to kind generic um so it's
just kind of like yeah that's no fine
but they don't really they're not
interesting you know what I mean they
just look like all the other ones stop
it poking so I like some I like some
interest yeah like even if you're like
kind of weird looking or if you have
like and like I said you have to be also
like charismatic you have to be like
interesting funny I like funny um you
know [__] like that Tammy says William
defo that's another one oh yeah William
defo is yeah not a not a traditionally
goodlooking super guy but magnetic women
like him yeah and it's he's got a
striking face and the roles that he does
and the way he handles himself women
like that yeah especially if he's famous
and got money oh that dude I mean that
helps too yeah but like I said even in
the wild po stop it Pooky oh my God up
the
paper she goes right over there to go do
it again we have Christmas paper over
she's like but I was in the middle of
something stop eating the paper no she's
like stop you can't tell me what to do
yeah she's don't yeah you can Zach says
z uh Jack Nicholson too yeah when he was
young um not so much now that he's older
he's a little I don't know well he's old
now that's an old gu that's what I mean
he's like old old but when he was
younger yeah he was like I wasn't super
into that but like yeah William defo
Steve Bashi um like I said Ted Cassidy
the original Lurch from I was really
into that I really liked um John
malovich I really thought he was hot
Jeremy Irons o I was all about Jeremy
Irons yeah mhm especially in dead
ringers when I ride around I go to these
a couple Starbucks that I go to and I've
been going there for probably about a
year or 18 months it's all the different
ones I didn't realize but over time time
all those people in there know my name
and I don't know their names they all
say hi to me when I come in and out and
I haven't said two words to those
people it's
just one of the things you know what I
mean [__] but if I went in there
[__] talking to everybody and [__]
uh flirting with all the [__] girls
or whatever it wouldn't be that way well
everyone think you were a a creepy
weirdo right cuz that's what creepy
weirdos do yeah no I go in there and
ignore everybody and just listen to my
stuff and but they all know my
name yeah they all come up and ask you
how I'm doing they all well see that's
what I mean it's like that's kind of
like what you're saying it's like it's
kind of better especially if you're a
dude less you do the better to be kind
of aloof yeah because if you're too much
and I'm not talking about like when
you're in a relationship like when
you're in a relationship obviously you
know you should pay more attention and
stuff but when you're just kind of out
in the wild yeah if you're too
interested if if you're too up people
[__] like it comes across as desperate
and weird and creepy and most people are
going to interpret it like that yeah so
and the fact that you look the way you
look which a lot of people don't like
you know you have the whole muscle thing
and you also have the kind of gothy
biker [__] and the biker thing yeah
which a lot of people and you always go
in there and you have all your gear on
and stuff yeah so you kind of Stand Out
we've noticed that like when we go to
like I told you pooky stop holy crap
she's trying to be the center of
attention no no she just she looks at me
all guilty and blinks it's okay it's
okay she just made a face like that but
the I mean we've talked about that like
when we go to you know the buffet and
then we go to the mall like we go to
over the we go to the buffet all the
Chinese girls know us yeah they're like
we're
special yeah they're always how are you
guys do they like Giggle and stuff and
it's
cuz we're in there all the time you know
yeah we look a lot different than the
other people that go there the other
ones are very overweight retired people
and they eat a lot we need to go there
tomorrow I'm [__] hungry but if they
eat a lot oh they that tie place we went
to last weekend God damn that was good
yeah you want to go there I'm thinking
about it okay yeah that's what happened
like told you pooky stop holy crap [__]
oh sh she went like that and like red
she wagged her tail like but then she
went back you're gonna you're in trouble
now you're in trouble don't try to
hide don't try to hide you're on the
show now you're on the show now you come
up here with Daddy stop making all that
noise see she's like but the paper yeah
yeah but yeah
so yeah we I mean we don't look like
anybody that's that goes to that
restaurant we don't look like anybody
that is in that mall like we go to the
mall where the bookstore is like get
coffee and stuff and we like watch like
yeah people are like looking at us like
we have three heads or something yeah
you know we live in kind of a it's a
rural is we're on the edge of the city
sort of but when we go over there it's
more rural yeah so it's like so we don't
look like everybody else that's for sure
compared to Mississippi this is Big City
yeah which is crazy because it's not to
her she she's
you know Daytona area yeah I grew up in
like red the redneck Riviera that's like
the Redneck city yeah so it's not Pokey
I told you she said I know Daddy that's
why you get down you get down Pokey get
down are you done sit okay she decided
she was done sit
okay but um but yeah so we got we I last
week here's what happened I don't think
we talked about this last week actually
last
Saturday I said you you know what I was
watching I think it was Hell's Kitchen
and I said somebody on there made pad
tie and I was like man I haven't had pad
tie in a really long time I was like we
should go get some of that so there's a
Thai
restaurant about it's not as far as
Jesus Christ it's ofon there much has
changed it's not as far as uh Ichibon
yeah um but here's what happened we
drove to the Place supposedly it opened
at noon we got there at like 5 minutes
before noon and we pulled in the parking
lot nobody else was there I looked at
the menu online I like yeah this looks
pretty good it's like reasonably priced
blahy blah so we get there and then noon
passes we wait 5 10 minutes Tom went up
and knocked on the door yeah they didn't
open yeah so I was just kind of like
okay [__] down um and Tom's like well do
you want to get to Hon instead I was
like no I really want some Thai food so
we looked on my phone and it's like
there's another Thai restaurant like 3
miles from here and it was in this kind
strip mall just strip mall there was
like a [__] Renta Center there was a
honey baked ham there was a Big Lots I
think it was Big Lots or something like
that in there and I think it was called
it had a weird name snay yeah snay taii
yeah and it just looked like a tiny
little whatever and I was and I was just
kind of like good man man it was so good
oh my God I got crab rangon which is a
Chinese dish and I said I want to see
what Thai crab rangon is like it was
[__] good they took the holy [__]
they took the W noodle they had uh the
cream cheese they had um uh canned crab
probably yeah yeah probably and then um
turmeric in there mixed in there and it
tasted like a little bit of sugar what
it tastes like to me and then they deep
fried it and they gave it to you to dip
into sweet kind of like a sweet and sour
sauce like a Thai sweet and sour sauce
yeah we split a we split an appetizer
man I said just those little just that
little just that little twist to that
Chinese rest to that Chinese recipe they
put a little tie twist to it man it was
great it was worth and the filling was
like it was like pillowy yeah yeah it
was like yeah I felt like there was a
little bit of egg in there like it was
super super fluffy it was hot you could
all burn yourself on it so that was what
we had as the as the starters and then I
had uh Ty red
curry um chicken thae hot thae hot it
yeah it was good it was I can cook T I
can cook t i can I could cook curry like
that too I know the the spice mix they
were using this comes in the can I think
it's called danani I think is what it's
called no that's the water that's the
water okay yeah that's the water
yeah s's water yeah no you go to the
Asian you go to the Asian market and
there's like Tha cans curry paste yeah
and it comes in a can like a tuna can
yeah there's like a yellow one a hot
pink one a red one a green one and one
other one and Jen got pad tie and that
[__] was great God it was so good it was
like pork in it yeah and it had some uh
invisible chick in her 40s with her mom
over there bragging about how many times
she's been to Thailand trying to get our
attention remember that she's trying to
brag to they were talking so loud I was
like well they came like after we
started Yanke Yankee tourists or or
retirees I didn't care she went to
Thailand but uh she was
announcing who gives a [__] and she like
I hate that I hate when people like talk
loud and they're like obviously just
like hey everybody be impressed with me
I'm like nobody is just shut the [__] up
like yeah you're invisible babe no one
cares you're younger than my wife and
you don't look half as good okay that's
what I was
thinking I didn't even see what she
looked like I didn't turn around that
you know
uh anyway the
um I was surprised that the food was
that good just in a little strip mall
and it was Thai people working there so
they knew the food was so good I think
it was a little family restaurant it was
really good yeah and it's like and you
wouldn't think that like just from the
outside like I said we just ended up
there because the one that we were going
to go to which is across from the trough
yeah it was a nicer place was yeah clo
like they didn't open in time so we were
like [__] this I'm hungry you know what
I mean so we just went to another like 3
miles away and it was so good I was like
really
surprised now I kind of want to go there
tomorrow all right I got to pee again
all right I don't know though man I'm
going to get another drink too cuz I
might want to P pile up on damn well
it's chicken and shrimp and [__] and I
want to see that movie I mean I don't
know if it's playing we'll check I just
got to check if the movie's not playing
then we'll we'll we'll have
TI and I got a [__] look I want to
tell you guys something
going back to Mississippi I inherited my
dad's truck but I couldn't I couldn't
bring it back it was an
F150 so uh my cousin is down there
trying to sell it he's going to send me
the
money but what I did [__] be was what
I did inherit was able to bring back was
all of my grandmother's [__] cast
iron all her cast iron cookwar I got two
little fried pant four big [__] fried
pant of different depths with lids on it
a huge cast iron pot with a [__]
handle on the top of it and a lid a cast
iron deep fryer it's about that big
around and about that deep and it had an
internal uh metal uh [__] like a a
basket with a cast iron lid on it wooden
handles and it was all from the 50s all
from the early 50s it was my
grandmother's [__] and I'm in cooking
with it and there's just nothing like
real cast iron that has been seasoned
since the
1950s you talking about non-stick you
don't need a Teflon you could cook an
egg on any of this [__] and it would
just slide across the top of it that's
how non-stick it
is and I was cooking U I cooked some Tha
curry in
it excuse me it was it was butter
chicken that's what it
was and I had the butter chicken in the
bottom of the the butter the chicken
fell to the bottom of the pan inside the
uh the sauce and it was still able to to
Brown even though it was
submerged in um in in in in butter in
butter chicken sauce that's how good
cast iron
Cooks I would probably think the only
other thing that would ever rival
whatever rival it would be [__]
copper copper pans but even though those
I don't think they're quite
as
nonstick copper can heat up fast but
there's something about cast iron and
then I took those cast iron pads and
made pad pizzas in them I got part of a
pad Pizza down there in the refrigerator
right now last [__] slice I was
telling about all the damn cast iron I
inherited that's right yeah he got like
a
hole brought that back in that rental
car in the [__] truck I haven't tried
the cast iron deep fryer yet we need to
try that out yeah let's some tempora or
something no no what I'll do is I'll
thaw those chicken thighs on the bone
that I have down there and I'll [__]
bread them and deep fry them like deep
fried chicken okay Southern Fried
Chicken or you know that sounds good too
yeah I'll do
that I don't how chicken you made maybe
two thighs will go in there at a time
I'm not sure but uh I just got to
experiment with that deep
fryer I mean the butter chicken you made
in the cast iron was really good I was
telling them the [__] chicken was was
Browning in the sauce yeah you didn't
have to Brown it outside of the sauce it
was in the sauce CU normally you would
yeah normally you would but that's how
good the conduction
was that ain't making me hungry
mhm I had a little bit of the butter
chicken earlier like yeah several hours
ago but you know what I
mean pretty as I am I'm need to start
thirst trapping these [__]
right trapping like the last time I
thirst trapped and got all those damn
super chats you might have to take like
your pants off or something I took my
pants off and
everything you look like you should be
in like [__]
um there he goes you look like you
should be in like London after midnight
or something he's stripping oh he's
stripping oh look he's got the he's got
the jockmail gay underwear on his gay
underwear stop it stop it that's all I'm
going to do that's all I'm going to do
see okay all I have to do is suggest it
and you'll do it suggest that [__] these
[__] don't know every now and then a
[__] got to
[Laughter]
demonstrate every now and then a
[__] got to demonstrate what you
think of that Zach go tell your
boyfriend oh my
goodness I love shows I love when The
Show Goes Like This said Tom should get
a what a a merkin I don't know what a
merkin is I feel like I've heard that
word before but I'm not sure what it is
I don't know what a Aman
is kind of oon said that's another shirt
dude what's another shirt wait your
underwear is another shirt yeah I don't
know I don't yeah you got to I don't con
I don't know the [__] quote
bro got a thirst trap a [__]
that might have been the down oh okay
yeah maybe I mean
yeah I do like all those gay underwear
that you have all my underwear are gay
they are pretty much G you don't have
those super rainbow if you no they're
not super rain they're all black black
and red black and red black and white
black and I think black
green yeah you do have the one that's
black and red that's like that has like
the ass hanging out though yeah yeah I
like that I got something that a cup
goes in it yeah yeah Pham cup he's like
here I got the I got these for you give
you [__] package
little it's hilarious hilarious well
like I said I'm performing in that [__]
man well you know I need to wear that
[__] to the club next time we go to the
club I'll start [__] dancing I'll
take my pants off while I'm dancing I
get my stripper pants like some [__] you
I'll put some I'll get that other pants
and I'll cut them down in the middle and
put Velcro so I can just pull them off
like a stripper yeah yeah on the dance
floor that would be awesome people would
[__] love it man they would go crazy
they probably would yeah cuz that is
totally some [__] that you would think
like yep that's s I'll do that [__] to
when Toby's out there oh my god oh man
[__] Toby showed up last time [__]
me me and Jim were dancing and Toby
[__] comes up starts dancing about
back up against the [__] DJ booth and
he's [__] going down on his knees
like he's blowing me the girls are
[__] Ling he wasn't blowing me though
it was just it just looked like it he
was just it just looked like it he's
just playing yeah yeah yeah he'll do
that with hand on his head he'll do that
with that he'll do that with the girls
too like the girl he'll kind of kneel
down and like pretend he's like eating
your puss but you know what I mean but
watch he'll put his hands up in
you
um he put his hands up and grab Jed's p
one time I didn't mind it was a long
time ago [__] he's a friend of ours
but he was drunk he was super drunk
super [__] drunk um it did surprise
me yeah cuz all of a sudden cuz you know
I was just wearing something that didn't
have any um if you're new to the show
Toby's my my club buddy and he's a uh a
leather daddy and he's a little bit
older than me he's a nurse that works
down at the [__] Orlando hospital
he's in real good shape [__] [__]
the girls it was I told him great and
he's a great he's aesthetic is great and
he's a really good dancer yeah and man
we've seen [__] over the [__] past 15
years with that dude he'd be out there
dancing and he's awesome I love him and
girls would just be [__] drooling
over him and I'd be talking to him
sometimes I'm
like it's like it's too bad you're dude
man you are [__] hurting these
women's feelings man [__] why are you
walking away from this [__] you know
what I mean [__] the got dud kill
he's like he's not into it it's just not
me like [__] you know not into girls
he's just not he's not into it no unless
he really likes you but he's going to go
to men yeah he likes he loves yeah set
me you got to be cool but he's into
dudes he's into black dudes he loves
[__] big [__] black dudes he likes
big musle yeah yeah he's very much into
now he's
[__] that dude's no joke man [__]
uh he's packing you can see he [__]
shows that [__] off that [__] [__]
comes around wraps around the [__]
side of his leg he was out there [__]
dancing and me and [__] Jenner
watching him dancing [__] watching three
girls just sitting there just [__]
looking at his package so hard like his
pants were going to catch off fire just
looking at his [__] bulge yeah yeah I
mean yeah it's big
yeah yeah [__] so you're not talking
about a little dick [__] he'd
[__] hurt you you chasing them a lot
of them gays he chase him away but he's
cool as [__] yeah he's real [__] cool
he's cool as [__] I'll show you picture
but I mean yeah yeah I'll show you
picture
everyone was drunk one night and and he
rides he's a biker and random uh fingers
went up in a place yeah bad [__]
and I was just kind of like I was going
to be mad and then I saw it was him and
he was like super drunk and I was just
kind of like that was a long time ago
I'll allow it yeah that was like years
and years ago it didn't surprise me
though because he kind of snuck up
behind me so I was just kind of like he
didn't realize what he was doing no I
don't think he did well and like I said
like I said if anybody if he was loaded
if a random [__] did that would
I will knock your [__] teeth out yeah
but I saw that it was him and he was
like super loaded and I was just like
yeah see when he gets up on her when he
gets drunk he gets up on her it's not
like uh it's not like a it's like
lesbianism there's just something
lesbian about it I don't know what it is
it is kind of yeah like I said he's not
really he's not into chicks but for some
reason he loves me I don't really know
why your personality he loves you cuz
I'm super no he told me he told me he
thought you were hot as [__] really long
time ago he's like man she's [__]
hot that's funny well he was
complimenting me I'm a um yeah I'm an
acquired taste yeah that's for sure all
right that's
Toby oh that's a good picture of him
actually yeah that's tell me yeah he is
rat as [__] I love him yeah and he comes
out like pretty much every goth night
he's out yeah and his big thing he's
older than we are Yeah by about five six
years yeah he's in his
50s um but man he loves the [__] 80s
New Wave [__] and like I said he's there
I think he's there every Saturday night
when they do 80s but [__] that makes me
want to go like do the 80s [__] tomorrow
night maybe we should do that he loves
them superhero [__] costumes and [__]
and he he bought this badass gym set
trying to get it together big Gym
machine he wanted me to help him put it
together but he's getting ready to go on
[__]
test although he he never follows
through that other guy fell followed
through which one Martin Williams
remember the big guy hold on hold on
hold hold
on but I don't know hold
on kind of sometimes a [__] got
a demonstrate yeah Tom's always got to
demonstrate what you talking about but
you taking your pants off earlier oh
yeah yeah
I mean to be
fair oh remember he actually got all the
information I like that dude yeah he he
got on the information and [__] um he
he's [__] hooked up with my [__]
International Brokers he's how old is he
he's a little bit older than me okay you
wouldn't know by looking at him well
because I've seen him forever and I
didn't really know how old he was this
is what gear can do to a female she's
[__] 56 years old yeah that's 5 years
older than I am yeah and and she's she's
fantastic and that's another um content
creator she's from Florida here but
she's also a fitness
instructor but it works on women
too yeah you don't necessarily have to I
mean I like I said I kind of feel like I
got lucky in the sense that I got jeans
for like young looking her mom's still
looks young yeah my mom is turning 70
yeah in a couple of days she looks like
padora yeah like I said I might go see
her this week because okay you know my
stepdad just died yeah so and I don't
know what she's gonna I mean you know
like like I said my brother lives around
there so he went out and helped her with
the funeral arrangements and all that
but and my sister's coming down from
Atlanta on Sunday and I would and I
always like to see my sister too so I
don't know I might go Sunday or Monday
or something but like I said you're
coming with me cuz I'm not driving all
that [__] by myself [__] that I don't
want that car breaking down me getting
murdered by leather face yeah you know
what I mean yeah Conor saying sometimes
a [__] got to demonstrate yeah
yeah I was trying to [__] thirst trap
and didn't even make any [__] money I
know I know that's what kind of cheap wh
I
am all I have to do is suggest it and
you'll do it oh my goodness oh my
goodness all I have to do is say it and
you'll do it yeah pry what time is it oh
[__] it's just turned 10 it's only 10
okay we're not going any place we're
going go yeah I don't want to do this
all night I'm getting hungry too I know
but it's like you know I'm having a good
time you do look kind of nice with the
long hair like I said you look like
you're I had to go to the I I had to go
to the [__] um Buffet like this you
already I to go to the buffet like this
go to the [__] Chinese buffet see if
they recognize they'll think that I'm
like with some other dude and they'll
like report guy yeah it's like hey um I
think might be cheating on you bro yeah
I got I'm like uh [__] heavy metal
Jesus yeah yeah heavy metal Jesus you
kind of look like who's that other who's
that band that's the like the gothic
metal band there's a lot of them the
main one you know what I mean why can't
I remember their name it's like right
it's right on the tip of my time daning
no God met man who was the one that did
[__]
um God damn it I'll don't remember it in
like what they do that's what I'm trying
to remember but I can't remember you
know what I'm talking about probably I
can see him I can see him in my mind
typo negative there that's it that's it
you look like the typo negative the guy
from typo that's how you look except he
didn't have little wolf skin boots yeah
he didn't have facial hair though right
no he didn't he yeah I he was [__]
super tall that dude too was he he died
of something did he some kind of heart
problem wait is he dead I think he died
a long time
ago I didn't know that yeah I think I
did died long time ago I didn't know
that if if memory
serves you look that up right I don't
remember that I mean it that could be
true I not I don't really keep track of
it but you know what I mean I wasn't
super up and up on a Gothic
metal like I peripherally was aware of
it but I wasn't really like into it
so so that dude could be dead I don't
really know I just you know I remember
seeing pictures of him at the time and
that's who you remind me of with that
hair on except for the facial hair name
Peter steel with it or Peter steel was
that his name uh I don't know don't ask
me I don't
know I don't
know yeah oh Danny says somebody said
what uh Zach said earlier about a merkin
yeah that is a fake It's a wig for your
pubes what kind of [__] is It's A Wig
it's a pub kind of [__] is that yeah he
died in 2010 at 48 oh [__] yeah of what
you
see see I didn't know
that yeah typo negative that's what I
was thinking of I have a couple other
songs on my [__] phone but it's like
for some reason I couldn't think of that
name to for the life of me I didn't know
that dude would Z
though that was never a huge fan
as a result of dependence on alcohol and
cocaine he developed problems with some
of his internal organs well um sepsis
what killed him [__] dude by diver 48
yeah there was reported his heart
failure at 48 that's what they always
say though
yeah drugs killed
him
man that's crazy I that's always crazy
like to think about when people are like
like that yeah or like younger than me
like that yeah and then they dropped
de that's [__]
crazy yeah Tammy's talking about all the
um all the stuff that she got from uh
her
grandparents all the cast iron stuff
yeah she got all the cast iron too I
mean that [__] lasts like forever yeah I
could believe Generations came home had
all that stuff I was just kind of like
holy crap yeah I come up in the damn
rental car and I'm like [__] look at
this this cast iron like what the [__]
is this you don't know this is a [__]
treasure
yeah it's working good though that was
[__] several hundred dollars worth of
[__] well yeah that more that [__] lasts
forever yeah invest in cast iron it's a
good thing it lasts forever
seriously they were talking about early
Guy Pierce oh yeah yeah and he was great
in Priscilla Queen of the Desert I still
need to show Tom that movie I love that
[__]
movie it's about drag queens I don't
know if you'd really be into it but Guy
Pierce was in it you know the dude that
played
um what's his name from the Alien movies
he was in uh what's that alien movie you
love so much Prometheus Prometheus yeah
he's he's in
Prometheus that's Guy Pierce he played a
drag queen when he was young in uh
Priscilla Queen of the Desert he played
a drag queen yeah it's funny it's it's
an Australian movie it's good
actually it's really good I've seen it
several times I might have it on DVD
actually now that I think about it a
bunch of DVDs over there yeah High
Desert knew knew about it yeah he yeah I
didn't know that he had died actually
like I said I wasn't ever a huge fan I
like a couple other songs but I hadn't
really followed them he's also a time
machine I like the time machine a lot of
people didn't like the time machine but
I liked it Guy
Pierce I remember it being okay I liked
it and had that dude that's down there
he was [__] with a
Morlock down in the cave with all the
white hair yeah it's a pretty good scene
who are you to judge millions of years
of evolution yeah that was [__] that
was a cool
[__] maybe we should review that yeah
I haven't seen it a long
time I've seen the original lots of
times and I've read the book too but
I've only seen that version one time I
think so um let's do a a quick U um
[__] survey with wig or without wig
what's
better probably with wig everybody seems
to like the
wig it's a different vibe different look
yeah I probably look totally different I
like you either way yeah you do look
like a totally different person yeah I
like you either way you look less
weirdly you look less scary with the wig
on really I mean you still look scary to
normal people I look more civilian yeah
I don't know if I'd get no I wouldn't go
that far I'm just saying that you know
you're just like with the bald head yeah
and all the stuff it's like you're just
kind of like terrifying you're going to
kill you and then it's like a couple
like a notch or two down now it's like I
might not kill you but I might like
sacrifice your baby what I need to do
now is I need to get one of [__] one
of those Star Trek Kling on outfits that
the armor see now yeah now you're
talking yeah now you're talking [__]
dress up like [__] Commander KW are
we going to do some videos like that
like some weird like [__] Star Trek
cosplay or something yeah do yeah we
could do [__] Star Trek
cosplay
porn I mean there's a there's a mar
dress as Klingons there's a market for
that yeah I could do that
yeah I can do that
yeah High deser said Tom just needs some
White pancake makeup and he could be in
a black metal band see that's what I
thought you definitely look like someone
who could be in like a death metal band
or like a goth metal band for real now
he's brushing yeah that's not the best
brush though it was the brush that I
grabbed that's not the good one the good
one is the one with the white handle
yeah the one with the purplish handle is
pooky's brush
so it's all full of cat
hair that one I don't use because it's
too
soft doesn't really work on my fine ass
hair you look nice though thank
you thank
you I don't know I kind I like it it's a
different it's a different vibe you want
me hit with this on huh well would you
yeah yeah sure yeah I'll put that [__]
on put your leg there
put your legs
out oh I put my legs out yeah put your
legs out now I [__] put this [__]
over my [__]
head I got you now oh my goodness I got
you now oh my goodness look at the
camera look at the I got you now I mean
it's a good thing I did my toes that's
all I can say that's funny holy
crap this is what happens this is what
happens around this
house
this is what happens around this house
he just comes in the office and he's
just kind of like I don't care I don't
care what you're
doing we're just gonna he's just gonna B
he's just gonna throw me right down the
floor and let [__] [__] it happens
sometimes it does happen sometimes he
doesn't care like brace yourself
woman it's all right though they're in
there
laughing they're in there laughing oh
okay I like it though yeah I like it
so hi says try porn oh there yeah
there's porn of that there's porn of
everything any little niche you can
think of there's porn of
that there's porn of
that sorry I just heard the cat heard
the
cat uh Danny says both versions of the
time machine were good yeah and the film
The Butterfly Effect pretty much ripped
off the guy Pierce time machine flick
but still decent yeah I remember that
being okay I haven't seen a long
time I haven't seen a long
time um let's see yeah everybody says
with wig with the wig yeah it's
funny I do kind of like it but like I
said it's weird because it doesn't
really look like you although the weird
thing about it is
that I don't know I've been with you a
long time so it was just kind of like I
I didn't know you bald at first cuz you
had hair all this time look at
you you had hair like most of the time
yeah you've only been bald like for a
couple of years with facial
hair and it's just funny to me that like
people that just know you with bald with
facial hair like think you look weird
with hair and with no facial hair yeah
but that's like how I knew you most of
of the
time but like I said I'm around you all
the time so it's not that weird you know
what I mean CU I see all the
transitions you know what are you are
you trying to take selfies of yourself
I'm sharing that [__] are you are you
send that [__] to
Laura yeah sent that [__] she's GNA be
like sent it to S oh my God he's sending
it to all the girls you know yeah two
two
I couldn't really see it all that good
so yeah it's not it turned out it's not
that good n it's like look at look at
this beautiful hair yeah that's
beautiful hair that I have beautiful
fake hair yeah I have my real hair on
today yeah that's Jen's real hair that's
my real hair
yeah I just didn't really feel like I
mean it's Friday I don't really feel
like putting a wig on plus I just washed
it right you know what I mean so it's
like all clean and stuff I'm down 30%
[__] power
Oh no I got another one though you got
another one yeah I got another one
charged up it'll be all right it's early
still two of these it's early still yeah
it'll be it'll be fine Danny says I like
the curly wig
better what curly wig oh the blonde the
Michael Kane one yeah that one that you
got when you were being Michael Kane in
the hand yeah yeah that's ridiculous
that was a great [__] costume yeah
when I did the hand yeah I wonder where
that [__] a blue jumpsuit is yeah
where did that go It's gotta be around
here somewhere where did the fake hand
go I I know that's here somewhere still
it's around here somewhere it's probably
in here someplace I mean there's so much
like [__] horror movie memorability
in here oh my God that was so awesome
like yeah he had like the blue jumpsuit
and the Michael Kane hair it was
actually a Willy Wonka wig Yeah Willy
Wonka wig was I think what they sold it
at but it looked like Michael Kane's
hair from that movie and it's like then
he had like the fake hand like on his
shoulder it was so good and I was just
kind of like he's like well nobody know
what that is I don't care I know what
that is and the people that know I going
to get some ant asses man it'll be
funny it'll be
funny yeah Denny says is he [__]
[Laughter]
you Tom still says that in the Michael
Kane voice sometimes
sometimes that's such a great movie I
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about it I saw it when I was a kid and
it freaked me out because when I was
well probably still nowadays but like
when I was a kid anytime that anyone's
limbs were severed well I was like I I
was freaked out by beheading big time I
still am but anytime anyone's limbs got
severed that like freaked me out big
time so I saw the hand when I was maybe
maybe 10 or
11 and the fact that the dude's hand got
cut off like in a freak car accident
which I thought oh my God that could
happen to me that'd be [__] up and
like that freaked me out so bad and then
like the hands like walking around and
stuff but it's such a good movie though
it's a great movie if you guys never
seen the hand it's Oliver Stone did it
that's his first movie yeah his first
movie it's his first movie it's based on
a novel but yeah and
um John milus guy who was doing stuff
like Conan he was involved in he was
friends with
stone
and kind of shows up in um the hand cuz
the guy mandro mandro is that was that's
the carene cartoon was drawn he's
cartoonist and it
was the two movies kind of go hand in
hand milus was doing Conan which was
basically about
masculinity okay Conan was actually like
a a very positive masculine
figure uh the if you go through we did a
whole show on it that Mythos is like how
to be a
man the rules of how to be a man is
that's what that that's what's in that
movie and what a woman offers you and
what your friends offer you and what old
men offer you um what your enemies offer
you that and that men are creation of
other men not just their mom and their
dad but the hand was about to xic
masculinity oh big time it was it was
reversed and and milus and stone were
talking about the movies that they were
making and the the scripts that they
were writing and it was supposed to be
that
um the Michael Kane character in in in
the
hand uh is [__] writing about a Conan
like character but he doesn't really
live up to Conan he's the opposite of
Conan in real
life his wife the hand is about
possession and being overly possessive
is a part of toxic masculinity there is
a toxic masculinity oh big time Big Time
but a lot of times you know women will
just throw that out they're you know
toxic no there there is a specific thing
that is toxic one of the things is to
not let people go and that's what and to
not let things go sometimes you lose you
have to let it go you can't try to keep
it it'll destroy you well if it's a
person that doesn't want to be with you
anymore you obviously can't keep that
that's really what the that's really
what it
was cuz that's what he was trying to do
he was kind of a possessive dude and he
was controlling and his wife wanted to
leave him and he wouldn't let her go
yeah and that was the the the main
underlying thing of the story and he got
weaker and
weaker uh but well no he got morally
weaker and he became more
murderous you know uh because he wasn't
letting her go which is not what Conan
would do so the two movies actually work
well together it is an interesting
double feature actually yeah it's like a
double feature
right but a lot of people don't know
that but you read the
uh there's like U the
commentary um I think Stone mentions
kodan and he mentions milus in the
commentary of of uh of hand yeah and um
there's just stuff that milus and stone
[__] were both kind of
um guys that believed
in positive masculinity sure you know
that they were that kind of dude and
that was
actually the story of Conan is the same
story of Apocalypse Now milus had a hand
in that too oh who who did that [__]
uh apoc now the director he was great
too Francis for copelan yeah he was good
too he listened to he listened to
millias about how legendary Tales should
be told and especially the the redo the
Redux the the full [__] the full
length director's cut version of
Apocalypse Now is [__] awesome and it
ends the same way as Conan
ends he gets up the river and finds out
that in a way Kurt is the Wellspring
from which he flows and that he sees he
sees CTS now and understands what kurts
told him about
Warfare but he kills him anyway and then
he leaves with he leaves he turns his
back on the cult he doesn't become part
of the warrior
cult in the way that you know thulsa
Doom or the way that colonal Curts
[__] had the [__] set up and he
leaves with an innocent and in Conan he
leaves with the princess he was supposed
to rescue and in Apocalypse Now he
leaves with um the surfer Lance because
Lance was an innocent too if you watch
real clearly if you watch closely
throughout the movie Lance didn't kill
anybody Lance was more of an observer of
the war he really didn't take a part in
it but uh it was a good uh Lance was
innocent it was just a good flick and it
was uh just another retelling of conam
well there's a lot of thought put behind
it I think like people storytelling yeah
I I think like some people are like they
watch a movie and it's just kind of like
and you do um like an analysis of it and
people like oh you're overthinking it
and stuff like that but that's not the
case no they thought about that I mean
they're storytellers they're writers
yeah so they think about all that milus
was great man he thought about the [__]
everything was Mythic another retelling
of Conan is Jeremiah Johnson mil milus
did that screenplay also and that's a
great Robert Redford movie and he was
the American Conan how I mean that's
partially based on a real on a story
supposedly real guy that's a lot of
stuff about liver Eaton Johnson may have
been a damn M uh part of it might have
been Tall Tales but he was a real old
west character mountain man he was the
American
Conan and um but uh all those movies are
should be M if you're a dude you need to
see those movies and you need to analyze
them because the messages in them are
true
mythology is true it's just a mythology
is a is is a way to tell stories to
teach you things and they teach
you uh principles that are um
Timeless like in Buddhism there's only
one kind of
Truth and and Truth is something that's
true and is always true a universal
truth other things are only true
temporarily and that's not true truth
like I'm I'm 54 that's true but it's
only a temporary truth next year I won't
be that age that's like a good example
or you know I'm strong now but that's
not a universal truth I won't I wasn't
strong before when I was a little kid
and I'm not going to be strong when I'm
on my deathbed everything is temporary
but there are some truths real truth is
always
true and sidhartha Goda the first Buddha
said the only there are only four noble
truths or things that are always true
one life is suffering that's always true
two you suffer because you desire things
that in the end will disappoint you
three as long as you're Desiring these
things you'll sense suffering at their
loss four the only way you can ever be
free from this is to reach nirvana which
is enlightened indifference and that's
actually that's shown throughout the
conad
movie uh that that lesson in there
that's also a little bit in Jer jiah
Johnson and the opposite of that is told
in the hand the hand is fa about failure
basically a failed man he becomes a
monster well he becomes a monster in the
sense that because he could not control
his wife the way he wanted to and he
couldn't control his dark emotions right
he either because they do leave it
ambiguous as to whether the hand
actually was going out and killing
people or whether he was doing it and
was attributing it to a paranormal too a
paranormal like you know he thought his
hand was doing it that was how he was
perceiving it they leave kind of leave
it ambiguous yeah but that's kind of the
thing about it is that you know
um what was I where was I going with
that um I totally forgot
yeah I had this whole like thing and
then I was just like what I I didn't
know where going you were going
somewhere good with it but I I was yeah
yeah but yeah I mean it basically is
about toxic masculinity I think we
because we reviewed the movie a while
back yeah and that and I think we
discussed that in this because it's like
he was the kind of person and he was
pretty much established at the beginning
as kind of a shitty person yeah he was a
shitty husband uh he was a shitty dad he
was a shitty man just in general well I
would call him mediocre yeah like not
yeah like not act
evil no and really his wife I didn't
agree with everything that she did her
Solutions I don't think were were good
but it didn't matter what the lesson was
is that she wanted to go there's no way
you right right and his and all of the
problems stemm from him not letting her
right be the way she cuz she kind of
went into more like new Agy kind of [__]
she started like going to yoga totally
and he kept like making fun of her yeah
right and just like belittling yeah she
started cheating on him with the [__]
dude yeah because it's like she was just
constantly being belittled and it's like
she couldn't leave a lot of it it it
basically stemmed from him and um he
just couldn't he couldn't uh he couldn't
let it go and
uh that that's kind of where he could
not accept loss hand trying to hold
everything right you know and that's not
the way reality is reality is about
things being transient they come and go
they come and go they come and go yeah
you can nurture a relationship if you
don't nurture it it will go or it's
going to go eventually anyway because
you're going to die or the other person
will die or you'll die together and
it'll go nothing is permanent yeah so
the idea is is that you live in the here
and now you try to do things to plan for
a good future if it doesn't work out you
have to get over you got to move on you
know you can't like well you can't well
you can't hang on to things and people
are you've lost anyway gone that you've
lost like that's not right and that's
that's that's really what the story of
the had was yeah about a [__]
who couldn't let go he was killing
innocent girls he killed an innocent
girl who liked him yeah but she was
going to [__] another dude yeah because
he was a teacher and he was like getting
into all the like students and stuff but
she she never it was never an exclusive
relationship to begin with yeah they
never go that's what I mean they never
established that right like she never
established hey I'm not going to [__]
other dudes no
she was just kind of a free spirit she
just [__] whoever she wanted at the
time yeah I mean she was a tried to keep
it and he was old right yeah and he got
mad he wasn't as old as you think he was
though he was only like 40 older than
her yeah she was in her 20s she was like
her dad's age but back in those days a
40-year-old dude looked a lot older
didn't he yeah he did yeah and honestly
I don't even know how old Michael Kane
was when he did that he's about
40 and she was probably about 25 yeah so
she wasn't that he seemed a lot I mean
the age seemed seemed a lot more a lot
more but I guess it wasn't wasn't that
bad 15 years maybe
maybe old people looked a lot older back
then yeah I've noticed young people
looked older back then they did yeah
everybody looked older yeah everybody
looked
older uh Danny says Dirty Rotten
Scoundrels is Michael Kane's best film
in my opinion haven't seen it it's good
you probably like it actually I haven't
seen it a long time but yeah it's funny
and Joseph says Zulu was a great debut
for Michael Kane yeah that was a good
movie too I a long time yeah Sabrina
said is was Apocalypse Now based on the
Heart of Darkness that's what I was
thought yeah Joseph Conrad's Heart of
Darkness yeah that's what apoc now was
based on it's just set in a different
setting and a slightly different lesson
yeah they updated it for the Vietnam War
because obviously the book was not set
in the Vietnam War but it was the same
general story yeah and a lot of stuff
shown in there was not accurate to the
Vietnam
War
um some of my squad leaders served in
Vietnam as infantry and they liked that
movie they were saying like no man
[__] Vietnam was most of those
firebases were [__] tight as [__]
everything was run by the numbers and by
the books there wasn't a lot of Chaos in
them but they had to show that as you
went up the river it got worse and worse
and worse as it got close to C yeah it's
not it's not a real it's not a
documentary you're right they're trying
to portray yeah um you know a fictional
they're trying to say something
thematically yeah um through the you
know through a realistic thing it's art
right it's it's not a docent now some of
the stuff that happened is based in
things that would really happen sure but
overall you it's an artistic
depiction of of a tale okay about a dude
who's facing the Heart of Darkness and
what the Heart of Darkness was was was
war true War not corporate Warfare like
America does or imperial Warfare true
Warfare is tribal Warfare and it's
genocide that's what real war is and
that's what Colonel Curts tells him he
says we put he goes you I found a pile
of inoculated arms and he goes and it
hit me like a silver bullet or like a
diamond bullet in my head if I had only
had a thousand men like this who could
do it the Purity The Genius of that the
our Pro our problems here in Vietnam
would be over very quickly so he started
to go out and assassinating the people
who were actually behind the war not
fighting soldiers because the soldiers
are just they're innocent you can kill
soldiers they just replace them with
other ones yeah you have to go after the
civilians that are waging the war
they're the ones that are actually doing
it and you can't spare anybody women and
children you know you're trying to
annihilate an entire enemy culture and
that's not the
way America and Empires wage war because
they're not really Waging War they're
trying to get something out of the
situation in the way a gangster would
try to get money out of a victim so
they're not trying to eliminate the
enemy they're trying to just weasle
their way into that system and make
money off of it it's a
project that's why we
lose if you don't want to [__] commit
genocide and war crimes don't wage war
that's what war actually is look at
5,000 years of human history all right
what it really was is what the Romans
did they just come in and just killed
every body stole everything and then
[__] took all the women back and sold
them as slaves to Rome that that's
really what it really
is um
so what we do to these other countries
you know and [__] you know I was a
part of it I word for them what we do to
them is really just enriching guys
enriching old guys and they'll make up
an excuse to attack a country you know
so they can make money it's [__]
ridiculous war is bad it is you only do
it if you just can't reason with these
people and really it's only Justified
when it's in Def fense you if they come
into your land and they're trying to
displace you and [__] get rid of your
way of life and replace it with their
own yeah you just show no mercy but
that's what we're doing to them we call
it bring in democracy man we didn't
[__] bring in democracy no you know
Iraq wanted to be Iraq Afghanistan
wanted to be
Afghanistan North Vietnam wanted to be
North Vietnam they wanted to be
communist who are we to go in there and
tell them what they couldn't do you know
it's just more ridiculous
[__] Danny says how about Danny Bole
making another 28 years later film yeah
I heard that was coming out can't wait
for that flick hopefully it won't suck
yeah um I don't know I think it'll be
good I'm optimistic we we'll see how it
goes I love that they actually waited
like actually 28 years and then they're
making 28 years later because they made
28 Days Later the zombie movie then they
made 28 Weeks Later yeah now they're
making 28 years later actually 28 years
later which I thought was kind of cool
Joseph said I found it hard to believe
that Robert deval's character would put
the solders lives in Peril just to Ser
uh yeah well what they were trying to
show is they were trying to show
different kinds of people
that are in wars and deval's what's his
name Colonel um what was that guy's name
oh [__] now I can't remember guy's name
I can't remember either I'll probably
think they were trying to demonstrate a
super
soldier who could do all this [__] and
loved it all right and uh he was just
eating it up and um he could kill the
enemy bring his men to Victory save
enemy children and women and wish them
he could he was multitasking through the
whole thing and uh that he would go home
totally
unscathed um that he he was like a total
winner but his Achilles heel was is that
the war would eventually end and when
the war ended his identity would be gone
that's why he said you know one day this
war is going to end and that's the
end yeah that was his whole entire yeah
his whole identity was based around that
right and in
the long cut of the
movie Willard steals that carel
surfboard yeah all right it had the
first that wasn't in the theatrical not
yeah and it's
because he was trying to emasculate him
he's like oh yeah that dude he's a super
soldier watch this I'm GNA take his [__]
he took his surfboard and then they they
hide it on the patrol boat and they
[__] go up River and they're hiding
and then for a couple scenes you'd now
hear helicopters flying over overhead
with the Colonel's voice going I'm not
angry just please return the
board they will be no retribution
against
you just please return my board yeah
yeah cuz that was like his that was the
only he had that was his penis ex that
was his penis yeah they emasculated
it I kind of wish they'd left that in I
mean I know it's in the extended version
so we can still see it they're hiding
the boat and and on top of the they got
the surf on top of the boat they got the
surfboard tied up there yeah and [__]
like a
trophy that they stole his [__] that
sounds like some [__] that I would do
yeah like look how much that dude loves
his surfboard that is like totally a
dick surrogate I'm taking
it yep yeah Willard steals it just
because he's got a wild hair yeah he
just sees the surfboard on the side of
the chopper he goes get it get it get it
they [__] run it and Lance Lance the
surfer he steals it that sounds like
some [__] yeah they just thought it was
like a goof like a big gag sure and they
try to escape with the surfboard but he
took it like way more serious oh yeah
sure I am not angry I will not retaliate
just please return the board he couldn't
stand not having it please return my
surfboard and it's a recording that they
plan of recording out like where instead
of the [__] ride of the valkyri
coming out of the helicopters it was CTS
not CTS what's his name [__] um [__]
what was his
name oh man I almost remembered it I
almost remembered what his name was
uh him begging for his for theet of his
cirb he says I ordered that he says I
ordered that from the United States that
was sent all the way from the United
States special order he's trying to make
him feel bad about taking it it was like
so
funny killgore Kilgore that's right Kore
Kilgore yeah that's right now dval said
that he was I could remember that either
dval said he he loved playing Kilgore
but he was disappointed that he didn't
wasn't given enough time to get to
totally jacked he was working out but he
wanted to gain like another 20 pounds of
muscle on top of that he wanted to be
[__] lot of Vaper [__] big upper
body but he didn't have a time cuz he
knew he had to do
shirtless uh [__] seeds he still
looked pretty good though he look good
yeah I remember looking at
yeah yeah Hugo said the DVD of
Apocalypse Now which we uh we have the
we have a Blu-ray doing that you the
Blu-rays are re the Redux yeah it's uh
comes with an extended interesting
version about 30 minutes 30 more minutes
yeah watching yeah that's what we're
talking about um and I think when we did
the review I think that's the version we
reviewed the longer version it also
includes the French that that stayed
behind remember the French uh the French
were still fighting in a certain area
there protecting one of their little uh
um protecting one of their little
plantations and uh
Willard has dinner with him and hooks up
with some chick French chick there it
has sex with her and they smoke Opium
but during that during dinner he finds
out the true history of Vietnam he
didn't realize that the French were
there for a long time yeah and that uh
that the whole thing was kind of
corrupt yeah I like I said I think they
took that whole sequence out of the
theatrical version yeah that's when
Willard realized that the Americans were
fighting for nothing yeah yeah I can see
why they took it out it was long it was
long yeah but I think kind of needed to
be in there yeah I think it kind of
needed to be it kind of showed
that America wasn't there to win that
war right and they knew that they
weren't there to win it was just a
project make money yeah so guys could
get promoted guys in the military could
get promoted still like I said it was an
important scene I can see why they took
it out because of pacing uh issues but I
think they probably should have left it
in there just like thematically because
it kind of made sense with the whole
thing but you know what you know what am
I Jo said an officer who did that get
fragged no no [__] fragging happened
in in in units that were [__] real
low
morale um [__] like aerosol units I was
in one they had a pretty high morale and
a lot of them were kind of borderline
Volunteers in there they had a lot of
spree of core they didn't really a lot
of times no they wouldn't have fragged
him they wouldn't have fragged
Kore um really the Vietnam movie I
haven't seen it in a long time but when
I was in service with the 101st Airborne
Division we saw a movie called Hamburger
Hill and they they captured it spoton I
kind of want to rewatch that I remember
that being really good yeah I haven't
seen it a long time
and some of my senior Squad leaders were
in those battles my first sergeant was
on Hamburger Hill he went up and down
went went up and down at twice and he
showed me a picture of all his friends
[__] dead l laying there on the
flight line where they were [__]
flying him out he say that because
that's all my friends wiped out the
whole platoon he was a 60 gutter at that
time his name his name was uh uh first
sergeant uh [__] pre what was his name
we called him hard rock I can't remember
what his name is he's in my yearbook
though but I forgot what his real last
name
was um been a long time it's a black guy
and [__] he never could adapt to
civilian in life he stayed in the
military the whole time he didn't want
out and that's
just even and I think he was drafted and
he didn't want it back out some dudes
just take to it some guys there's a love
hate relationship even Willard says it
in the movie says when he was in Vietnam
all he thought about was going home but
when he got home all he could think
about was going back to Vietnam yeah and
he's just home I think that happened a
lot yeah and he's going like uh went
home and you know he's the guys on the
boat are talking about going back home
and Willard goes yeah they all want to
go back home but they don't realize
that's not there anymore home isn't
there anymore because what you're
imagining you're imagining a fantasy
life that you had before service back at
the home that life is gone when you go
back home you're going to experience it
very
differently so that's why a lot of guys
stay in
service some guys never really
psychologically leave it
yeah part of pizza
TSD yeah I can see that yeah cuz you get
addicted to it yeah get addicted to
really [__] high adrenaline rushes
lots of testosterone and
stuff that's why the suicide rate is
high yeah because you're living way up
here then all a sudden you got to go
back to regular life you go man I'm Joe
[__] the rag man I'm like Joe Snuffy I'm
nothing here the world that I grew up in
it was back in a battlefield somewhere
and I want to go back home with my
friends if they're not around anymore
that Battlefield is gone they kill they
start drinking then they kill themselves
yeah like I said it happened a lot
yeah Tammy said um I really liked
platoon was actually the first time I
saw Willam defo yeah yeah that's a great
movie I think we review that it's a good
movie uh it it's a it has a lot of
artistic license taken in it sure I
think the guys that wrote it were in
Vietnam uh not totally accurate though
they're just trying to show you trying
to give civilians a story I remembered I
haven't seen it forever I remembered
Hamburger Hill being accurate we should
probably rewatch that because like I
said I haven't seen it in a long time I
remember it being really good but I
haven't seen they put every one of those
dudes through basic training so they
basically were uh a uh AER assault
infantry they had all the skills you
could tell by the way they're handling
weapons and everything that they they
were trained and their lingo and how
they talked and everything that was that
that was even in my era we still spoke
like that and how they showed aerosol
operations what infantry actually does
when they're on the ground it's not
Hollywood at
all but yeah well like I said you can't
you know [__] on movies too much for
like oh it's not realistic because
they're not trying to be realistic yeah
they're just trying to tell a story
they're just trying to tell a story and
like an interesting story that people
but I remember I remember seeing
Hamburger Hill and that there was
nothing wrong with it like everything
was like yeah that's it like in ham in
in [__] um platoon
they weren't wearing uniforms they were
very rarely had any headgear on in other
words there was no helmets or hats or
anything their hair was not cut right it
was
long that's not the way it actually
looked you'll see photographs from
Vietnam of guys just in a t-shirt you
know what I mean with no hat on or no
helmet on but they're taking that
photograph when they're when the
Patrol's over they're taking off all
their gear and their their power
powering down they're not out in the
field like that usually they were
[__] they were [__] loaded for
bear and wearing all their gear [__]
Flag vest [__]
helmets but um I remembered Hamburger
Hill just being spoton and everybody in
my unit watched it and they were like oh
that was the best ever the most accurate
ever you know all the way down to the
little details of how they wore things
you know all their LC their their Alice
gear how they handled weapons you know
it was just like you looking at real
soldiers cuz they went through
training they said the training was
rough too the guys that were in that in
that
movie also Joseph says the Brian De
Palma movie casualties of war was based
on a true story we should probably see
that too CU I don't think one Michael J
fox is it I don't think I've ever seen
it's one of Michael J fox where they
captured that girl and killed her I
think that's oh yeah yeah yeah I know
what you're talking about yeah it was it
was a crime that happened Joseph also
said Tom was the boot camp portion of
Full Metal Jacket accurate well that was
that was a Marine Corps boot camp and
that would have been accurate for the
time um when I went in I was at went to
Sand Hill with Fort Benning Georgia I
was uh Alpha 254 Alpha second and 54th
infantry which is a training
unit and it was war time it was the
first Gulf War was going War started and
joined it was like something out of
damn looking back on it it was like
something out of that damn [__] movie
with the bugs uh Starship Troopers oh
okay it's like that um yeah our drill
sergeant were [__] ferocious and the
one that I had was his name drill
sergeant how and he was running it by
himself for a while and then shye came
in and [__] poock and then there were
three of them on us but they were short
of drill sergeant at that time so we had
one for a while it was running in ragged
and how was this 6 foot2 black dude who
ended up coming to to Korea with us at
after we got a basic how showed up to
Korea and he made him a damn squad
leader so it was a trip to see your
platoon sergeant in your unit as a as a
as a squad leader it was [__] great
to see him he ended up being a preacher
last I checked he's a [__] Minister I
think in
Georgia um he was [__] ferocious man
uh and funny as [__] it is a lot like
what you saw in Full Metal Jacket
because that was Lee iry and Lee iry was
a drill sergeant yeah and he but that
was more of a marine
style it was worse actually than what
you saw in full mail that because
they're just showing you one thing that
that drill sergeant did you know making
dudes choke themselves and [__] yeah did
they did things like that back in 1990
during war time what they can't express
to you is how tired you are I mean we
were waking up with nose beds from iron
deficiency they're not feeding you much
they're just running you into the ground
they're running you through this
training course and it's absolutely
ruthless and they're not letting anybody
sleep you're constantly pulling
firewatch Duty and if a dude [__] up
they wake up everybody in the middle of
the [__] night to do bear crawls and
[__] crab crawls across the
[__]
the [__] dorm we call a dorm we call
Barracks uh yeah dudes got beat up they
[__] threw a [__] mattress on top
of sturchio and [__] everybody jumped
up and down on him um because he ate
cake they found him he ate cake he ate
two cakes so it became cake
day yeah went to the CH line and he got
a cake and he put a [__] bowl over
soup bowl over so he couldn't see it and
asked for another cake got two cakes and
drill St saw that so sterio decided to
eat cake twice he got to today is cake
day y'all are [__] up y'all can't K
you know just it just Mass
punishment um yeah Cake Cake Day CI day
lasted about [__] six
hours [__] man Sero got beat up for that
but sto ended up being a good dude later
on because they they sent the whole
platoon to Korea we were a we were what
was called a cohort platoon they didn't
spread they didn't break us apart after
you got out of basic training they sent
the whole platoon as a as a packet of
Replacements to in in my case first in
the 506 AER assault infantry Camp
Greaves Korea at that time the 506 was
in second Infantry Division but it had
been on loan from the 101st Airborne
Division for about 30 40 years it's now
back with the 101st where it belonged
but in those days it was with the second
ID and after I did in did a year in
Korea they sent us all from anybody who
came from first and 506 unless there's
special circumstance anybody came out of
506 Went to went to Fort Campbell and
became part of the
101st some dudes went to Ranger school
though and um went to 75th infantry with
Ranger regiments that was [__] bad
[__] man that was in the back in the day
when an Army Ranger was a [__] psycho
crazy you're basically volunteering to
go to a concentration
camp when you come out of Ranger school
you're going to be a [__] skinny wiry
half starved skull people we call them
skull people because they come back they
just their head just look like
skulls because it's not about building
you up or making you strong it's one
long nut check to see how much
punishment you can take food and sleep
deprivation and you got to run combat
Patrols in different environments
um you got to know everything about
defense call for fire you know which is
mortar air strikes and [__] artillery
it's just basic infantry basic infantry
skills it's just that the the difficulty
is like on [__] 10 they just maximize
the difficulty on everything
by denying you sleep and denying you
food the whole thing is to try to make
you quit it's not to make you stronger
or make you into a [__] Superman it's
just uh a nut check they want to see if
you'll quit the only dudes that will not
quit are guys that are basically [__]
suicidal you know uh they want a dude
that will fall on his own sword
basically but how do you do that and get
and some dudes died during training uh
when they made it [__] easier over
time though but there were guys that
were dying from hypothermia and
exhaustion it's not what it used to be
I've been hearing it now where Fe
females two females passed it it had to
been [__] rigged or would because
dudes couldn't pass it you'd have
[__] out of a 100 strong Dudes Only
third 30 would pass
it it's just unbelievable
misery Hugo says what is your view on
Paths of Glory have you seen that I
haven't seen that one all right talk
some more I got
yeah more I got
a the deer hunter has some memorable SE
yeah I remember liking the deer hunter
it had some good scenes I don't know how
accurate they were probably pretty
accurate maybe but the P
scenes one of the ones I liked that had
Christopher Walkin in it though was Dogs
of
War
and it was a story about a mercenary and
there is [__] some kind of accurate
[__] in that for the
era um where [__] Walkin plays this
mercenary and he gets involved with
these other guys and one of the dudes in
his unit was a Frenchman who played
bellock in [__] Raiders of Lost Arc
he's in it and uh they're going to
Africa to uh overthrow a government
there and get like uh another guy
installed so that was B that was
basically what that one was
about there were some things about it
they were kind of hokey Walkin did not
make a really good
[__] Soldier or mercenary in it in a
certain way he was kind of like uh odd
he was a little odd youd yell a lot when
it really wasn't called for but there
was something kind of odd about the way
he played that character where I liked
it came off kind of being a little bit
of a
psycho but I don't think it was intended
I think it was just that walking
really you know how walking is walking's
[__] silly man but I I liked Dogs of
War that was pretty cool I liked that as
well yeah it was an odd
flick I haven't seen the deer hunter in
a long time I you know what I don't
think we we didn't review the deer
hunter did we uh no I haven't seen it in
a long time I wouldn't mind seeing that
again I really like that movie actually
yeah but it's been a while since I've
seen it been a while
H all right it's almost 11 yeah it's
almost 11 it's almost time I'm getting
hungry yeah me too kind of
yeah me too grina all right so I guess
we're going to wrap it up for the
evening oh he's taking the wig off going
it Oh no I got so used to you like
having the hair on now you just want me
to have that hair on a jumping bed with
you no I'll probably get my mouth and
stuff get that [__] in your mouth you
get other things in your mouth well yeah
well you know how that goes yeah but uh
oh Danny says where's that raccoon
commercial uh where is it it's down here
somewhere there it is is that racco
there we go that was just for you all
right so um so we're going to wrap it up
for this evening Friday night we're
going to go have something to eat get
some butter chicken get some butter
chicken and uh you know then we're GNA
do some [__] over the weekend have a
good time whatever so we'll be back
Monday evening doing a movie review I
don't know what movie it's going to be
cuz we watched it yet but you'll find
out when we do so that should be fun but
thank you everybody for coming and
hanging out with us this Friday evening
thanks for your super chats and all of
that uh we will see you guys again on
Monday night good